GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVE IN NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS. AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. FOUR
WILL BE HERE IN THE- THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK LASTED
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME WE'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO UNMUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON ME BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING OUR IT PERSONNEL WHICH
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS HELLO. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX ONE TWO. FIVE
TWO EIGHT EIGHT FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATED TO DIAL
ONE ZERO PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LOT A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED IN YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THE CONNECTIONS. MADE
WE'RE GONNA GO GET AHEAD OF GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED AND- TODAY
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING WILL
COVER THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS ON COMBAT IN RETAIL
THEFT AND GUN VIOLENCE I WILL
COVER PROPOSALS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. WE
WILL HEAR FIRST HERE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THEIR
PROPOSALS AND THEN WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AFTER ALL ISSUES
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. ALL ISSUES
WILL BE HELD OPEN AND THERE WILL
BE NO VOTES TAKEN TODAY. ALL
WILL BE WE WILL BEGIN WITH THE
ITEMS PROPOSED FOR DISCUSSION.
THE FRST ISSUE. ISSUE ONE IS
COMBAT IN ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT. AND START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND SET IT ASIDE
JUST IN A MOMENT APARTMENT
FINANCED IS PROPOSE A REQUEST A
HUNDRED SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE TEN
POINT NINE MILLION IN TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX AND FIFTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY.
TWO TWENTY. SORRY TWENTY TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN AND ONGOING.
SUPPORT THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
SUPPORTING VARIOUS INITIATIVES
TO COMBAT ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT. THE PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TO DEVELOP AND
DISTRIBUTE GRANTS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED OR SUFFER DAMAGE
COSTS CAUSED BY RETAIL THEFT
INCIDENTS. SPECIFICALLY AND FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THIS AFTERNOON'S
HEARING THIS REQUEST INCLUDES
THE FOLLOWING FOR THE SEC C. H.
P. AND D. O. J. NINETY FIVE
MILLION FOR THREE YEARS FOR THE
BSE SEATED ABOUT AN EMPLOYMENT
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
PREVENTION AND VERTICAL
PROSECUTION GRANT PROGRAMS. SIX
MILLION FOR THREE YEARS
INCREASING TO TEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. FIFTEEN MILLION
TWENTY SIX AT TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN ON GOING FOR THE C. H. P.
TO EXPAND AND MAKE PERMANENT
IT'S ORGANIZED RETAIL. CRIME
TASK FORCE. AND LASTLY SIX
MILLION FOR THREE YEARS
DECLINING TO THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. AND FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TWENTY. TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN AND I'M
GOING FOR THE DOJ TO SUPPORT
REGIONAL TASK FORCES COMBATING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. AND TO
PROSECUTE CASES THIS PANEL
COUPLE JURISDICTIONS AT THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
THESE FUNDS WILL FOSTER OPEN
COMMUNICATION COLLABORATION. AND
INNOVATION TO REINFORCE A WHOLE
OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT IN CALIFORNIA. TODAY I'M
JOINED BY SEVERAL COLLEAGUES
HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS WELL AS SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS FROM THE SEC. C.
H. P. AND D. O. J. AND WE ARE
AVAILABLE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. FROM MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AS IT'LL OF. LA LAW OFFICE.
THANK MANAGER CAITLIN O'NEILL
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WE ANALYZE THESE
PROPOSALS AND ISSUE ONE AS WELL
AS PROPOSALS AND ISSUES TOO AND
FOR- ON TODAY'S AGENDA AS PART
OF A BROADER PUBLIC SAFETY
PACKAGE PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
THAT CONSISTS OF NINE PROPOSALS
AT FIVE WHICH DEAL WITH
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT TO WITH
FIREARMS. INTO ITS DRUG
TRAFFICKING OR OTHER CRIMES WE
RECENTLY PUT OUT A PUBLICATION
THAT CONTAINS OUR ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS PACKAGE
I'M GOING TO GIVE IN- HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF OUR- COMMENDATIONS
AN OVERARCHING COMMENTS ON THE
PACKAGE AS A WHOLE. AND THEN
TURN TO SOME SPECIFIC COMMENTS
ON THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. AND SO MOVING
INTO THOSE OVER TEN COMMENTS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER APPROVING TWO OTHER
PROPOSALS IN THE PACKAGE THAT WE
FOUND IDENTIFIED AS BEING
REASONABLE. AND THOSE ARE TWO
MILLION ON GOING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER AT UC DAVIS.
WHICH IS BEING HEARD IN
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE- AND THE
DOJ TASK FORCE PROGRAM FUNDING
WHICH IS ISSUE FOR ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. REGARDING THE REMAINING
FUNDING WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINED ITS
HIGHEST. PRIORITY PUBLIC SAFETY
GOALS SPECIFY CLEAR OBJECTIVES
AND THEN ONLINE FINDING IN A
MANNER. THAT ENSURES ITS GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES ARE ACHIEVED. AND
THIS IS BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S OVERALL PLAN
LACKS CLEAR AND SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVES FOR ACHIEVING EACH OF
ITS STATED GALS- AND WITHOUT
OBJECTIVES IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ASSESS
WHETHER THE PROPOSALS WOULD BE.
EFFECTIVE IN INITIATING OUR
CALLS- FOR EXAMPLE- THE GOALAND
THE VARIOUS TYPES OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES THAT CAN FALL WITHIN
ORGANIZED RETAIL FAST AS DEFINED
IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE THAT CAN RANGE FROM TWO
PEOPLE WORKING TOGETHER TO- SHOP
LEFT AND RETURNED MERCHANDISE
FOR STORE CREDIT TO A CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATION THAT IS EXPLOITING
OR EVEN TRAFFICKING PEOPLE. TO
STEAL ON ITS BEHALF AND SO
WITHOUT CLEAR AND SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVE IT'S OBJECTIVES IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHICH OF
THE VARIOUS TYPES OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE REALM OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. ARE
INTENDED TO BE TARGETED BY THE
GOVERNOR- AND THEN WITHOUT. AND
KNOWING WHAT ACTIVITIES ARE
INTENDED TO BE TARGETED IT'S
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY. SPECIFIC
ACTIONS THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
EFFECTIVELY PURSUE THOSE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES- OR THOSE
TARGETED OBJECTIVES WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
PRIORITIZE CRIME REDUCTION AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR. CRIME
DATA SUGGESTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S SPECIFIC GOALS AS
REFLECTED- IN THE PACKAGE MAY
NOT BE WELL TARGETED. AND WHILE
THERE'S NO OFFICIAL DATA ON ALL
REAL RETAIL THEFT IN CALIFORNIA
THE CLOSEST REALLY DATA POINT WE
HAVE A SHOPLIFTING- THAT DID
DECLINED SIGNIFICANTLY BY NEARLY
30% BETWEEN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY. WHICH SOME AMOUNT
OF THAT DECLINE IS LIKELY DUE TO
STORE CLOSURES AND PEOPLE MOVING
HOME DUE TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS STATE
HOMEOWNERS IN ONE NIGHT. DURING
THE EARLIER PART OF TWENTY
TWENTY- AND PRELIMINARY DATA
FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE DOES
SUGGEST THAT OVERALL LARCENY
WHICH INCLUDE SHOPLIFTING IS.
INCREASING BUT IT HADN'T
RETURNED AS OF OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS SO SORT OF THE TAKE AWAY
IS THAT WHILE YES CRIME. MAYBE
INCREASING OUR RETAILS HAVE MADE
INCREASING IT APPEARS TO BE IN
THE CONTEXT OF THAT- I DID
DURING A PRETTY SIZEABLE DEBT
DURING THE EARLIER PART OF THE
PANDEMIC- IN CONTRAST. THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS- I HAVE SEEN
INCREASES IN HOMICIDE AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT AND MOTOR VEHICLE THEFT
THAT COULD MERIT- ATTENTION. IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
HOWEVER THAT AND WHILE THERE IS
NO. DATE LINE OFFICIAL
STATISTICS- SOME EXPERTS AND
RETAILERS HAVE OBSERVED AT. AN
ANECDOTE IT ANECDOTES- HAVE
POINTED TO INCREASED CRIMINAL
SOPHISTICATION AND LEVEL OF
CRAZINESS AND VIOLENCE INVOLVED
IN INCIDENTS OF RETAIL STAFFED
SO THAT COULD WARRANT AND
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
ALTHOUGH AS I NOTED THERE ISN'T.
VERY GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SCALE OF THOSE- ISSUES. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT CRIME DOES TEND TO
TEND TO VARY BY- PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY SOMETIMES BY
REGION AND TYPE OF CRIME SO
WHILE RETAIL THEFT MAY NOT BE OF
SIGNIFICANT STATEWIDE CONCERN IT
COULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
MAKE SENSE TO TARGET- IN
PARTICULAR AREAS OF THE STATE.
UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN CRAFTING ITS OWN
PACKAGE FOCUS ON ADDRESSING
ADDRESSING CRIME RELATED PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS OUR PUBLICATION.
HAS VARIOUS OPTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER THAT
GENERALLY EXPAND ON EXISTING
PROGRAMS OR- SUGGEST OPTIONS FOR
. I DIRECTING FUNDING TOWARDS
RESEARCH BASED TOOLS OR
STRATEGIES SUCH AS- AMPLE
CAMERAS ARE USE OF OUR GPS
TRACKING TECHNOLOGY TO REDUCE
RETAIL THEFT. FOUR TWO AND MORE
EFFECTIVELY. ADDRESS IT- AND
THEN IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT. M. CRIME IS AT A
HISTORIC LOW RIGHT NOW SO IT
COULD BE REASONABLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SIMPLY
PRIORITIZE- PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS
THAT ARE NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
REDUCING CRIME. THAT CONCLUDES
MY OVER ARCHING COMMENTS AND
THEN I'LL JUST TURN TO OUR OUR
TWO MAJOR AND CONCERNS THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO THE PROPOSALS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. BEFORE I
CONCLUDE AND THOSE ARE FIRST
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
THREE YEAR- PROPOSED THE SEC
GRANT PROGRAMS WHICH ARE TWO AND
TWO OF WHICH ARE IN THIS AGENDA
ITEM AND ONE IS IN THE NEXT-
ITEM WOULD PROVIDE THE SEC WAS
SIGNIFICANT IMPLEMENTATION
AUTHORITY AFTER THE BUDGET IS
ENACTED. AND BECAUSE OF THAT
IT'S CURRENTLY UNCLEAR HOW THE
FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOCATED AND
USED- WHETHER THE PROGRAMS WOULD
BE EFFECTIVE- AND IT MAKES IT
HARD TO RULE OUT THAT THE GRANTS
WOULD NOT- SUPPLANT LOCAL
FUNDING. FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW THE FUNDING WOULD
BE FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WE
WOULD BE USED IT COULD END UP.
GOING TO INCREASING LAW
ENFORCEMENT PATROL OF RETAIL
LOCATIONS TO PARTICIPATING IN
TASK FORCES. OR TO PURCHASING
CAMERAS OR OTHER EQUIPMENT ALL
OF WHICH COULD HAVE DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES AND BE- OF THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
EFFECTIVENESS. AND THEN SECOND
CERTAIN PROPOSALS MAY NOT BE
TARGETED OR EXCUSE ME MAY NOT BE
STRUCTURED TO ACHIEVE THEIR
DESIRED OUTCOMES. FOR EXAMPLE
THE CHP ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
TASK FORGET FORCE EXPANSION
COULD FACE CHALLENGES BECAUSE
HE- C. H. P. CURRENTLY DOES NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DEDICATE
FULL TIME OFFICERS TO THE
PROPOSED NEW TASK FORCE IT'S-
DUE TO A HIGH. THEY CAN SEE RATE
WHICH WE- ARE CONCERNED COULD
IMPACT THE OUTCOMES ACHIEVED.
AND THEN WE KNOW THAT DOJ DOES
HAVE EXISTING EXPERIENCE IN
MANAGING TASK FORCES-
PARTICULARLY THOSE. TARGETING
COORDINATED CRIMINAL GANGS ARE
NETWORKS AND SO DOJ COULD BE A
BETTER AND- ENTITY TO ADMINISTER
THE ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT TASK
FORCES. THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS AND. I'M AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
WITH A NAIL- OKAY WE COME OUT
THE MY CALL- QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SIR. YES SIR COURTESY.
THANK YOU FOR THE MANAGER JUST A
QUESTION FOR THE ADMINISTRATION-
THE NOTICING IN- TO THE L. A. O-
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THERE'S MORE
QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS.
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION SO
I DID THIS BUT I KIND OF HAD A
SIMILAR REACTION PARTICULARLY TO
THE FIRST. PIECE OF THIS THE
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION OF EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR GRANT
PROGRAM. TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET IN I IDEA. AS TO WHAT THE
VISION IS FOR THE FLOW OF THOSE
DOLLARS IT IS EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS
DIRECTLY TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
FOR EXAMPLE AND THEN THE IDEAS
THAT THEY WOULD DECIDE. HOW TO
BEST DEPLOY THOSE DOLLARS.
THROUGH THERE ONE FOR SOME
ORGANIZATIONS OR- IS IT GOING TO
BE MORE SPECIFICITY I'M A TRYING
TO IMAGINE. HOW RETAIL. TENDS TO
WORK- IN RELATION TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT- IN OUR ARIAN IN
PENCIL CAN VALUE TENDS TO BE-
RESERVE OFFICERS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY DIRECTLY PAID FOR BY
THE CITY BUT ARE PAID FOR-
TYPICALLY RETIREES THAT ARE PAID
FOR THROUGH A SEPARATE
ORGANIZATION AND OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF RETAILERS- AS WE ALL KNOW-
REALLY PROVIDE THEIR SECURITY
THROUGH- THROUGH PRIVATE
SECURITY SERVICES- THE DATE THEY
DEPLOY AND THAT THEY MANAGE-
PRESUMABLY I'LL JUST SAY. IT'S
NOT PART OF MY QUESTION BUT I
WOULD ASSUME THAT BETWEEN THERE
AREN'T. FOR MOST RETAILERS
BETWEEN THEIR INSURERS AND THEIR
OWN. RISK ANALYSIS LOSS
PREVENTION THEY WOULD INVEST IN-
IN EITHER RESERVISTS OR OR
SECURITY OFFICERS THEMSELVES
THAT SAID. LET ME JUST GO BACK
TO THE SIMPLE QUESTION HOW WILL
THIS MONEY FLOW TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES IS AT THE IDEA. I'M NOT
SURE THIS IS KATIE HOW ARE WE
YES YOU SEE I'D LIKE TO JUMP IN
IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU AT-
CENTER CORTESE HI GOOD AFTERNOON
KATIE HOWARD WITH THE ARTISTIC
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS- I WOULD
OBSERVE GENERALLY. THAT OFTEN
WHAT HAPPENS AS- THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES NEW KINDS OF GRANT- YOU
GUYS GRANTS IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT HE HAS TO
SEE IF MINISTERS. THERE MIGHT BE
A BROAD GOALS STATED INITIALLY
AND THEN AS WE WORK THROUGH THE-
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING PROCESS AND
GET MORE INPUT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY THE
ANALYSIS OF THE- ALLEY- MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE. YOU KNOW I THINK
AS WELL THAT WE OUGHT TO BE-
SPECIFYING WHAT THE OBJECTIVES
ARE HERE- TO THE FIRST PART OF
YOUR QUESTION CENTER CORTESE.
IS- THE- GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THIS
FUNDING IN TERMS OF THE EIGHTY
FIVE. MILLION DOLLAR PORTION
WHICH IS. ANNUALLY FOR THREE
YEARS AND YOU KNOW. WHAT THE
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES WOULD BE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AT THE CITY
LEVEL AND THEN. THE SHERIFFS AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. AND HOW
THE DSCC MINISTERS GRANTS-
PARTICULARLY COMPETITIVE GRANTS.
AND WHEN WE GET INTO- ITEM TOO I
MIGHT MAKE SOME OF THE SAME
POINTS- FOR EXAMPLE THE-
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION GRANT CELTIC I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD. SORT OF
PARALLEL WE HAVE WHAT WE CALL AN
EXECUTIVE STEERING COMMITTEE
PROCESS I KNOW MANY MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE AWARE AS
WELL AS MY- COLLEAGUES ON THE
PANEL. WE BRING TOGETHER SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS TO COME TOGETHER
AND CRAFT A GRANT PROPOSAL SO
THEY SET OUT- ALL THE SPECIFICS
IN TERMS OF WHO'S ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY BUT THE GRANT AMOUNTS CAN
BE AND THEN. AS YOU WERE ASKING
ABOUT. WHAT KINDS OF ACTIVITIES
AND PROGRAMS AND THINGS WOULD BE
SUPPORTED THIS FINDING. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A COMPETITIVE
GRANT WITH LATE ALL OF THOSE
THINGS OUT. SO I THINK THERE'S
SOME REALLY GOOD BALANCE BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE BY ALL MEANS
FEEL FREE TO. FURTHER SPECIFY OR
EVEN PERHAPS. TIGHTEN THE FOCUS
AROUND. ORGANIZED RETAIL STAFF
BEING THE- CONCERN. IT RAISED
MAKES SENSE TO ME WE TALKING
ABOUT THE IN X. OBVIOUSLY LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF THIS AND
GRABS THE HAD BEEN OVER LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS AND GET MY MORE
DRAMATIC WAY BUT- OUR GRAND WITH
LATE OUT- QUITE ON COULD
PROPOSALS WOULD BE SO. AN
THERE'S ALL- YOU KNOW LANGUAGE
OUR CREDIT THAT WOULD
DISAPPOINTING CONCERN YEAH I
AGREE IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT
A NEW GRANT PROGRAM WOULD PAY
FOR THINGS THAT ENTITIES COULD
BE FINDING ANYWAY THE IDEA HERE
IS LIKE YES IS TO HAVE NEW
TARGETED RESPONSIVE ACTIVITIES
TO THIS. ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
CONCERN. JUST A FEW THOUGHTS
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY OTHER. THANK
YOU. AND THEN TAKE A FOR THE
THOROUGH- A MUCH BEYOND MY
EXPECTATION- EIGHT I APPRECIATE
THE VISION FOR HOW THINGS WILL
WORK AND THEN HOW.
IMPLEMENTATION SO SECURE
COMMUNICATION. CRITERIA OR GRANT
WRITING CRITERIA WILL COME.
SHORTLY AFTER THE LEGISLATION.
AND IT IS TO THE INVITATION FOR
ANY. LEGISLATIVE COMMENT-
GUIDELINES ON THIS OR DIRECTION-
I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT WILL
UNFOLD THROUGH A LARGER. A
BUDGET COMMITTEE- AS INTO
ARCHER- I'M SHOULD BE A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE TORTURE ON THIS BUT I
DO I DO WANT TO SAY I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH- BESIDES THE CONCERN
ABOUT REDUNDANCY WITH. WHATEVER
INSURANCE FOR. INSURERS IN IN
WELL HEELED WITH RETAILERS ARE
DOING ON THEIR OWN. THE IDEA
THAT IT IS GOING TO RUN THROUGH
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
BECAUSE I THINK- THAT TAKES CARE
OF A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER ISSUES.
RELATIVE TO. THE WAGES- BENEFITS
CONCERNS. LIKE THAT THAT THAT WE
ARE. IT A SENSE OF- HE HE SUNK
OF BLOOM DOES- WAGE PROGRAM- YOU
KNOW TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AND
I KNOW THAT WOULD BE THE
GOVERNOR'S INTENT FOR SURE BUT I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
AFFIRMATION OF THAT IDEA I THINK
ONCE YOU'RE COMING THROUGH THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES- THEY WILL
IT LEASED OUT THE WAGE AND
BENEFIT FRAMEWORK ALREADY. SET
UP POLICE IN THE MOST
RESTRICTIONS- BASED ON THEIR
OWN- GOVERNING BOARDS AND
COUNCILS AND SO FORTH TO MAKE
SURE- THAT- THAT THAT PIECE OF
IT'S TAKEN CARE OF SO THANK YOU
. WELCOME MMHM SENATOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
OF I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
ABOUT SHOES GONNA ANSWER BUT-
I'M ALL FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
GETTING FUNDING AND I'M ALL FOR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- GETTING FUNDING TO
ACCESS- OR HIRE ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE I KNOW I
PERSONALLY SHE'S ARE SHORT SO
I'D LIKE SOMEBODY TO TELL ME HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THAT I
THINK LOS ANGELES JUST- SAID
THEY WERE GONNA LAUGH ALMOST
FOUR THOUSAND SHERIFF'S OFFICERS
SO WITH THE SHORTAGE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND MY FIRST
QUESTION IS AND HOW ARE WE GONNA
RETAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE
ABLE TO- TAKE ON THESE
ADDITIONAL CAP TEST. S. IT'LL
HAVE A START THERE IN ALASKA. AT
THE TIME I APOLOGIZE- THIS
HOWARD DO YOU WANT TO. SURE
SOMEWHERE I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
THAT- THIS IS A- MY SENSE OF IT
- CENTER GROVE'S IS THAT THE-
ENDED YOU WANT TO. DECIDE THAT
THEY WANT TO APPLY FOR A
COMPETITIVE GRANTS SO THEY WOULD
KNOW IN A PARTICULAR. DEPARTMENT
WHETHER THAT'S AT LEAST
DEPARTMENT OF PROBATION ENTITY
OR SHERIFF'S OFFICE THAT THAT
THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES TO APPLY
FOR A GRANT TO GET FUNDING TO
DIFFERENT STRAINS- I CERTAINLY.
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THAT YOU
RAISED ABOUT- SOME OF THE OF THE
HIRING AND RETENTION ISSUES THAT
FACE LOTS OF DIFFERENT PARTS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND DON'T REALLY
HAVE A GREAT ANSWER FOR YOU ON
THAT IN THIS CONTEXT BUT WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS- IT'S NOT AS IF.
ENTITIES WOULD GET THIS FUNDING
TO DO THINGS THAT ARE NOT IN A
POSITION TO HANDLE OR MANAGE
THEY WOULD AUTOMATICALLY DECIDE-
THERE'S THIS BARGAIN NICE RETAIL
THEFT GRANT WE WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND COMPETE. SO I THINK THAT
WOULD. SORT ITSELF OUT SOMEWHAT
NATURALLY. OKAY YOU AND I ONCE
THEY GET THIS GRANT- IN THE
ARREST THESE PEOPLE LIKE FOR
INSTANCE THE LADY AT VENICE
BEACH AT THE RITE AID WITH A
PICKAXE WALKING AROUND. WITH A
PICK AXE ON HER SHOULDER- JUST
FILLING UP A BASKET AT LEADING
SO I GUESS WEN THEY WHEN THEY
GET THESE GRANTS- ARE THEY GOING
TO BE ABLE TO ARREST AND
PROSECUTE THESE INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW UNDERCURRENT
LAW THEY CAN'T SO. ONCE THEY GET
THE GRANTS IN ORDER TO STOP
THIS- THIS VIOLENCE IS
ESCALATING VIOLENCE AND ROUTE
YOU KNOW THEFT AND EVERYTHING
THAT SMASH AND GRABS AND ALL THE
STUFF THAT'S TAKING PLACE IN OUR
STATE- DID YOU KNOW THERE IS A
GUY THAT. COMMITTED WAS ARRESTED
SIX TIMES IN ONE DAY FOR
COMMITTING- THEFT. ROBBERY AND
THEFT. BUT THEY CAN'T PROSECUTE
HIM OR HOLD THEM SO ARE THESE
GRANTS GONNA DO SOMETHING TO
HELP. I DON'T KNOW ARREST AND
PROSECUTE HIM PUT HIM IN PRISON
IN JAIL SO THEY DON'T NEED TO
CONTINUE TO COMMIT THESE. CRIMES
AGAINST OUR LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
THAT ARE BEING HARMED BY THIS IS
THERE SOMETHING IN THERE A
PROVISION OR SOMETHING THAT
ALLOWS THAT TO HAPPEN. ARE WE
JUST GOING TO GIVE THEM FINDING.
THEM AND THEY CAN APPLY FOR
THESE GRANTS THEY CAN DO THE
SPECIAL- THE SPECIAL. CASS FORCE
M. HIRE ADDITIONAL OFFICERS. BUT
NO ARREST OR PROSECUTION WILL BE
ABLE TO TAKE PLACE I GUESS NOT
ARREST NO PROSECUTION WILL BE
ABLE TO TAKE PLACE ONCE ARRESTED
. AGAIN CAME A HARD ALL ALL JUMP
IN IF I MAY CENTER ALSO- AS YOU
HAVE SEEN IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COMPONENT OF THIS PROPOSAL- THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PUT FORTH SHE
DOES CONTEMPLATE- VERTICAL
PROSECUTION GRANTS FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ABSOLUTELY.
PROSECUTION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTING ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT CRIMES. IS CONTEMPLATING-
I WOULDN'T WANT TO OVER PROMISE. ON THIS- YOU KNOW. WE WOULDN'T
BE TO. WORK OUTSIDE OF WHATEVER
ABILITY THERE WOULD NEED TO BE
PRESENT FOR- ARRESTS AND
PROSECUTIONS- BUT I WOULD I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO CONTEMPLATES-
INCREASED RESOURCES TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR PROSECUTION OF
THESE CRIMES AND THEN IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW- LOCAL ENTITIES
WOULD GET FUNDING. TO DO A
VARIETY OF ACTIVITIES WE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE REQUESTING
INFORMATION AND DATA AND THAT'S
BACK TO SENATOR CORTESE'S
QUESTION AS WELL SO THINGS LIKE
OKAY YOU'RE GOING TO GET THIS
GRANT- WE NEED REPORT- YOU KNOW
QUARTERLY. DATA TO BE SUBMITTED
ON. YEAH NUMBERS NEW OR- YOU
KNOW THROUGH THESE. AND
PROSECUTIONS CONVICTIONS ALL
THOSE KINDS OF DATA ELEMENTS
THAT WOULD HELP THE LEGISLATURE
AND EVERYONE ELSE WAS INTERESTED
TO SEE THE FUNDING HAS GONE OUT
AND HAS BEEN SUFFICIENTLY
TARGETED ON GOALS THAT MAKES
SENSE TO BE ABLE TO BE. ASSESSED
THAT MEASURE IN SOME MEANINGFUL
WAY WHAT POSITIVE DIFFERENCE WAS
MADE. OKAY AGAIN I DON'T SEE THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN- HOW THE
FUNDING PROVIDING THE FUNDING
AGAIN I'M NOT OPPOSED TO FINDING
I'M JUST SAYING I DON'T SEE HOW
THE CORRELATION OF PROVIDING THE
FUNDING. WILL ALLOW- DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS TO PROSECUTE FOR
INSTANCE THE LADY WITH THE PICK
AX OR THE GUY WHO COMMITTED THE
SAME PROPERTY CRIME OR THEFT
CRIME SIX TIMES IN ONE DAY WAS
ARRESTED BUT WAS REQUIRED TO BE
LET GO. UNDER PROP FORTY SEVEN
AND OTHER LOOK LAWS AND POLICIES
THAT HAVE COME OUT OF THIS
BUILDING I'M I'M ASKING FOR A
LIST I'D LEFT MY LIST BACK BACK
AT THE OFFICE THAT HAS THE
ENTIRE LIST OF ALL THE- SOFT ON
CRIME POLICIES THAT HAVE GOT OUT
OF THIS BUILDING. SO I JUST AM
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IN THIS IS
MY QUESTION. FINDING THESE
ORGANIZATIONS. HOW IS THAT GOING
TO ALLOW THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
TO PROSECUTE THOSE ARRESTED.
JUST BECAUSE THEY HAVE MORE
MONEY BECAUSE IT'S NOT A FUNDING
ISSUE IN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WERE. I REPRESENT THREE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES. THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO PROSECUTE THEIR
HANDS ARE JUST TIED. BECAUSE OF
THE POOR POLICIES THAT COME OUT
OF THIS BUILDING AND LIKE PROP
FORTY SEVEN. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS. HOW IS THIS FUNDING
CAN ALLOW THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
HAVE TO VIOLATE PROP FORTY SEVEN
OR THE POLICIES THAT ARE IN.
EXISTENCE EIGHT. TWO ARE
PROSECUTE THESE INDIVIDUALS JUST
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FINDING. YEAH
AGAIN KATIE HOWARD WITH THE BSE
SEEING THERE IS A CRIME-
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT SO I
THINK THAT'S THE AVENUE THAT
WOULD BE- PERSON WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS GRANT. ON THE
OTHER POLICY CONCERNS THAT YOU
RAISE I THINK FALL OUTSIDE OF
THE SCOPE OF THIS GRANT. HAPPY
TO SEE IF MY COLLEAGUE JUSTIN
HAS ANY ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS TO
ADD ON THAT. YEAH JUST A MOMENT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST TO
REITERATE WHAT MISS HOWARD SAID-
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT IS
DEFINING PENAL CODE FORTY NINE.
FOUR NINETY POINT FOUR- SO ANY
OTHER CHANGES TO LAW WOULD MAKE
IT. OUT I'M. FROM THE LIKES. AS
FAR AS WHAT IS ON FOR DISTRICT.
IN TO PROCESS. OKAY I GUESS I'M
I'M NOT I'M I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY ABOUT
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT- WHERE
YOU HAD EIGHTY PEOPLE SHOW UP
SMASH AND GRAB WALK OUT WITH A
THOUSAND DOLLAR OR SKEWS ME NINE
HUNDRED NINETY DOLLARS A PIECE
SO THAT YOU CAN BE PROSECUTED.
AM I GET THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE CRIME THAT OCCURS EVERY
SINGLE DAY- IF THIS IS JUST FOR
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. AM I
UNDERSTAND THAT I UNDERSTAND THE
FUNDING TO THE CHP AND OTHER
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFF. FOR
TO HAVE A SPECIAL UNIT TO
ADDRESSORGANIZED- CRIME RETAIL
THEFT. I GUESS MY PART IS WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT- I HEAR FROM
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ALL OVER THE
STATE THAT THEY CANNOT
PROSECUTE. THESE CRIMES. BECAUSE
OF PROP FORTY SEVEN AND OTHER
POLICIES THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
THIS BUILDING- SO I EAT. AGAIN
HI I AM TRYING TO JUST TO FIND
OUT HOW THE FUNDING IS GOING TO
HELP- HOW THE FUNDING IS GOING
TO HELP GET. HOW THE FINDING. OF
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT TRYING I'M-
EXPLAINED IT ONCE I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO EXPLAIN IT A
DIFFERENT WAY. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW. GIVING SOMEONE
MORE MONEY REGARDLESS OF WHAT
DEPARTMENT IT IS WILL HELP THEM
PROSECUTE CRIMES THAT THEY ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO PROSECUTE UNDER.
IS I GUESS SHIN THIS IS KATIE
HOWARD IN ON THEM FROM THE SEC
I'M SORRY SURE YEAH I JUST.
HOWEVER YOU CAN GIVE THE BEST
ANSWER TO THE SENATOR BECAUSE AS
SHE SAYS SHE'S ASKED THREE TIMES
BUT WILL GIVE IT ONE LAST SHOT
THANK YOU- AND HOPEFULLY THERE'S
MORE TO THAT AND I GUESS THAT
YOU KNOW THAT DIRECT QUESTION IS
THAT HOW IS GIVING FUNDING TO
WHATEVER ENTITY IT GOES TO
WHETHER IT'S LAW ENFORCEMENT
DISTRICT ATTONEY'S OFFICE IT
DOESN'T MATTER. HOW IS GIVING
THEM ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
ALLOW THEM TO PROSECUTE AGAINST
THE LAW THAT DOESN'T ALLOW YOU
TO PROSECUTE THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND PROP A PROPOSITION THAT
DOESN'T ALLOW YOU TO PROSECUTE
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT'S WHAT
I'M TRYING TO FIND OUT. AND I
THINK- THE ADMINISTRATION IS- IT
IS FOCUSING ON THE CRIME OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT WHICH IS
IN A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT LANE
IF YOU WELL. FROM OTHER KINDS OF
FAST- AND OF COURSE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS- WELL I WOULD. RATHER
NOT GET INTO ALL THE CHALLENGES
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S FACE BUT IT
IS IT IS CLEAR THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
THERE'S A LOT. OF WORK THAT CAN
BE DONE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
GRANT GOES AFTER. DIRECTLY AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU
RAISE ARE SIMPLY OUTSIDE OF THE
SCOPE OF THIS GRANT. OKAY SO
JUST AND THEN ONE MORE QUESTION.
FOR IS IT GOING TO BE A
DIFFERENT QUESTION YES SO FOR-
FOR INSTANCE- THE TRAIN ROBBERY
I GUESS YOU WOULD CALL IT THE
TRAIN ROBBERIES DOWN THERE WHERE
IT LOOKS LIKE A THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY THAT'S THE GOVERNOR'S
WORDS- WE'RE ALL THESE PACKAGES
ARE STOLEN. IT'S JUST BASICALLY
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN PEOPLE YOU
KNOW FROM THAT AREA NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT COME DOWN ONE TRAIN SLOWS
DOWN THEY JUMP OFF THE GROUND
THE STAFF. IT'S NOT REALLY
ORGANIZED CRIME BUT THEY CAN'T
BE PROSECUTED SO IS THAT WILL
THIS HELP. TYPE OF SITUATION.
BUT JUST A MOMENT APART OF
FINANCE I COULD JUST JUMP IN
REALLY QUICK ORGANIZER THEFT. IS
DEFINED IN THE PENAL CODE IT IT
IT DOES INCLUDE JUST ACTS IN
CONCERT WITH ONE OR MORE PERSONS
TO STEAL MERCHANDISE. SO THAT
CASE REQUEST IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY LIKE SOME. YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT CARTEL OR OR
NECESSARILY HAVE. YOU KNOW A
LARGE NETWORK OF FOLKS BEING
INVOLVED IN THE CRIME ITSELF
IT'S AS DEFINED IN THE PENAL
CODE- INVOLVING MULTIPLE PEOPLE
IN RETAIL THEFT. TRAINING SAMPLE
THAT YOU CITED GROVE WOULD BE
INCLUDED POTENTIALLY. CAN CUT
NINETY FOUR I'M SORRY TO SAY
WOULD OR WOULDN'T IT COULD IT
COULD IT WOULD DEPEND ON THE
PROSECUTION AND THE SPECIFICS OF
THE CASE OBVIOUSLY I DON'T HAVE
THAT KIND OF LEVEL OF EXPERTISE
TO SAY BUT- THE PENAL CODE THAT
DEFINES ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
IS PRETTY BROAD IN THAT IT
DEFINES YOU KNOW ANY KIND OF
COLLECTIVE OF INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THE- CRIME OF RETAIL
THEFT BEING- PROSECUTABLE UNDER
BACK IN OKAY. THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SURE- AND
ONE. COMMENT WITH ARE AMONGST
OURSELVES RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO
ASK HIM SOME QUESTIONS- AS FAR
AS WHAT WAS IT THAT WHAT
INFORMATION WHAT DATA THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAVE TO HAVE. TO
DECIDE THAT ORGANIZE THIS
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT WOULD BE
THE HIGHEST OUR PRIORITY CRIME
THIS YEAR FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION- BECAUSE I THINK
THAT KIND OF DATA THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION REALLY SETS THE
FOUNDATION FOR YOU KNOW A
DECIDING THE TOTAL FUNDING
LEVEL- HOW MUCH ADMINISTRATION
WOULD. LIKE TO SEE. DISTRIBUTED
TO MAYBE TO PUT AREAS I'M NOT
SURE BUT THE DOZENS THEM AT
LEAST I DIDN'T SEE WHAT IT WAS
THAT MADE THE ADMINISTRATION
DECIDE THIS WOULD BE THE HIGHEST
CRIME PRIORITY CRIMES I COULD
SEE WHY. IF YOU WATCH A LOT OF
TV AND YOU SEE THE SAME CRIME
ARE BEING SHOWN HUNDREDS OF
TIMES OVER AND OVER THAT PICTURE
OF THE- PACKAGES OUTSIDE OF THE
TRAIN STATION WAS IN MY
DISTRICT. THIS IS NOT A THIRD
WORLD DISTRICT AND IT'S NOT A
DISTRICT WHERE PEOPLE JUST COME
OUT AND START YOU KNOW STEALING-
THAT'S NOT THAT WITH THAT
COMMUNITY IS BUT YOU SAW IT ON
THE TV HUNDREDS OF TIMES. ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY SO WHAT WHAT IS
BEHIND THIS I GUESS AUG TWO JUST
MAKE THAT PROPOSAL AND WHAT IS
BEHIND THIS TOO- DECIDE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. AND HOW IT WOULD
BASICALLY BE- DISTRIBUTED
THROUGH GRANTS. ENGLAND RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR- WE JUST WANTED TO KNOW
IT YOU KNOW ONE OF THE- CONCERNS
OF THE LA- EXPRESSED I BELIEVE
YOU JUST DID AS WELL AS FAR AS
PRIORITIZING THE CRIME IS. IT
MINISTRATION HAS INVESTED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS IN RECENT
YEARS AND OTHER TYPES OF CRIMES
AS MISSED OUR IT PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED ON THE LAST PAGE IT
AFTER ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CAL A BIT PROGRAM WHICH IS THAT
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION PROGRAM- WE ALSO
INVESTED YOU KNOW ELEVEN
MILLION. FOR THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICE TO FACILITATE
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
IN TRAINING- BY THEIR
INVESTMENTS AND KIND OF ANTI GUN
AND CRIME PREVENTION IN OTHER
AREAS. AS TO ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT WE YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD
FOR SEVERAL YEARS- THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALSO PRIORITIZED-
THROUGH VARIOUS BILLS YOU KNOW
IMPLEMENTING C. H. P.'S
ORGANIZED CRIME RETAIL TASK
FORCES IN THIS PROPOSAL BUILDS
ON THOSE- MY EXPANDING BESSIE T.
TASK FORCES TO FRESNO AND
SACRAMENTO AREAS AND KIND OF.
TAKING ON A BROADER STATEWIDE
APPROACH TO THE CRIME- AS WE'VE
SEEN IN RECENT YEARS AND AS YOU
MENTIONED IN THE NEWS- IT'S KIND
OF BECOME. A AT ISSUE. GOTTEN
SICK MORE PUBLISHED RECENT AND
SOME THAT WE FROM WE- SIXTY.
THAT IT'S A CONTINUING ON
PROBLEM AND IT'S ONE THAT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING
COMPLEXITY AND REQUIRES KIND OF
A LARGER COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
FROM STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- AS FAR AS THE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS WE BELIEVE THAT
IT WAS. NOT A SUITABLE AND
ADEQUATE. FOR THIS LEVEL OF
FUNDING TO KIND OF EXPAND THE
CHP PROGRAMMING AND PROVIDE
THESE GRANTS TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S WITHIN THE OVERALL. OUR MOUNTAIN IN THIS
PARTICULAR LANE THIS CONTRACT
WOULD BE REALLY BENEFICIAL IN.
COMBATING ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
IN CALIFORNIA. FROM. YES THE
TASK FORCE- IS PROPOSED TO BE
SITUATED WHERE IT IS SITUATED AT
THE C. H. P. RATHER THAN AT D.
O. J. HOW DOES THIS KIND OF
ACTIVITY- FIT INTO THE CHP'S
MISSION. AND THEN ALSO THERE IS
I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE PARTIALLY
ADDRESSED THIS IN TERMS OF
STAFFING ISSUES OVER TIME
ISSUES- HOW IS IT AND WHY DO
THIS THROUGH THE C. H. P. RATHER
THE DOJ. JUST A MOMENT SIR I CAN
I CAN I GUESS FOR TED C. T. AS
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE INSIGHT I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT- EIGHTY
TEN SIXTY FIVE AND EIGHTY THREE
THREE ONE BUT ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED THEIR CRIME OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT AND- ON A
TEMP. BASIS THE CP PROGRAMS- BUT
ASFAR AS WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY GOING I WOULD PREFER.
TO SEE PETE ON. THANK GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER CHATER READ. MY
DAUGHTER IS HERE WITH ME THAT
SHOULD BE THE ENGINE. TO TOUCH
ON THAT JUST A LITTLE BIT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU WHEN THE LAW WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- WE ASK YOURSELF THE
SAME QUESTION WHAT IS THE HARD
DRIVE TO BE WITH RETAIL THEFT
BUT- ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT WAS
A NEW CRIME. AND A LEGISLATOR
ASKED US TO TAKE ON ESTABLISHING
THE STATE TASK FORCE WHICH ARE
NOT NEW TO US AND WE DO HAVE
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN RUNNING
TASK FORCE BUT TODAY WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FOUR MEMBERS SERVING ON
NINETY SEVEN DIFFERENT TASK
FORCE. MANY OF WHICH WE TAKE THE
LEAD ROLE ON. AND I JUST WANT TO
BRAG A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT OUR
FOCUS IS DONE WITH RETAIL THEFT
SINCE. TWENTY NINETEEN- WE- IN
OVERNIGHT OR AT RETAIL CRIME BUT
- FREE. TWENTY POINTS MILLION
DOLLARS IN STORE MERCHANDISE AND
HAVE MADE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT. ARRESTS IN RESULTS THAT.
I THINK IN OUR EXPERIENCE WE
FOUND THAT- THAT'S THERE'S A LOT
MORE WORK OUT THERE TO DO.
THERE'S THE ABILITY TO EXPAND
INTO OUR OUR VALLEY AND INTO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- AND WE THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT REASON THAT-
RUSSIAN ABOUT THE OVERTIME AND
THE STAFFING- WE TALKED AOUT
YESTERDAY WE DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
VACANCY ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH ABOUT A THOUSAND
VACANCIES. ON THE OFFICER RANKS
AND ARE ASKING IS THAT WE WOULD
USE THIS FUNDING TO- USE OVER
TIME TO KIND OF BRIDGE THAT GAP.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE NEXT OF
WINE AND THEN AS WE FILL THOSE
VACANCIES WILL DEVOTE RESOURCES
TOWARDS THESE GENES IN THOSE
AREAS AND WITHOUT COMPROMISING
THE LEVEL SERVICE- ABOUT IT NOW
. OKAY- SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
OTHER PART OF THIS ALSO GOES TO-
SOME PORTION OF THIS WHAT IS IT
TEN MILLION GOES TO SMALL
BUSINESSES IN WHAT WAY IS THAT
MONEY GOING TO BE USED WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES. I JUST NEED
ONE PARTNER FINANCE
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY HERE FROM THERE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. FOR BUSINESS
AND ECONOMICS. DISCUSS THAT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS- THAT
WOULD GO TO SMALL BUSINESSES FOR
GRANTS- SOME FOURTEEN I CAN'T
COMMENT ON THOSE. SPECIFIC.
COMPONENT THIS PROPOSAL AT THE
TIME AT THE TIME. OKAY. HOW ARE
WE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDS ARE ARE TARGETED WHAT IS
IN THE CRITERIA THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BE TARGETED TO-
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME AND NOT
TO OFFSET OR INCREASE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUDGETS. I'M JUST
NAMING AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I THINK JUST TO REITERATE WHAT
MISS HOWARD SAID IN INTERNET
MARKETING STRENUOUS POINTS HIS
BAT IN MINISTRATION IS OPEN TO
CONTINUING. NEGOTIATION ON THE
DETAILS ABOUT HOW TO POTENTIALLY
NARROWER KIND OF CLARIFY SOME
ISSUES AND SO I THINK WE WOULD
BE OPEN TO SPECIFY. YOU KNOW
SUPPLANTING OF EXISTING FUNDING
FOR THESE CRACKS. AND HOW. WILL
YOU MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
RACIAL EQUITY. A PARTICULARLY
WHERE THERE ARE. ALL PATTERNS OF
OVER POLICING OR- ISSUES OUT
WITHIN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THIS IS KATIE HOWARD WITH THE
PSPCL I'LL JUMP IN THERE- YEAH
GRANT CRITERIA COULD SPECIFY
GOALS LIKE THAT- AND
PARTICULARLY WITH DIRECTION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND YOU KNOW
IT'S PART OF THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT- IF THERE IS. ANY ANY
KIND OF PARAMETERS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO. ADD ON
YOU KNOW AND OBVIOUSLY WITH-
YOU'RE NEGOTIATING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THEIR
RESEARCH- AND GREEN MEANT THAT
ISSUES OF RACIAL EQUITY SHOULD
BE PAID ATTENTION TO AND THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY
THOSE COULD BE BUILT RIGHT INTO
THE GROUND CRITERIA. OKAY
TONIGHT I WOULD SAY- ADD TO
THAT- THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN OBVIOUSLY I'VE I THINK
THE- ESPECIALLY WITH THE TV AND
THE MEDIA PROMOTE- YOU KNOW
THERE'S SHOPLIFTING AND THEN
THERE'S THE LARGER PICTURE OF-
ORGANIZED CRIME CRIME RINGS. SO
HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE HOW DO YOU
GET INTO THAT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING HERE. YES THIS IS
KATIE HOW ARE YOU IT'S REALLY
HAD A SIMILAR RESPONSE- ANY
COMPETITIVE GRANT THAT GOES OUT
WHAT. GENERALLY BEGINS WITH THE
PROPOSAL NEEDING TO STATE THEIR
PROBLEM AND HOW THE ACTIVITIES
THAT THEY PROPOSED TO UNDERTAKE
WILL- ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC
CRITERIA SO. IT REALLY WILL
DEPEND ON WHAT THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA ARE WHETHER IN THE
AREAS OF FOCUS ARE NARROWED TO
YOU KNOW SOME TYPE OF SCALE OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT OR WHAT
HAVE YOU- YOU KNOW THERE THERE
IS A WAY FORWARD TO GRANT YOU BE
SURE TO. SPECIFY WHAT IT'S GOING
AFTER. RIGHT AND I. ASSUMING THE
THERE'S- SUFFICIENT DATA IN THE
FIRST PLACE WHICH I THINK I
WOULD COME BACK TO IS- I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED THE BASIS FOR THIS
TYPE OF INVESTMENT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN- REALLY DATA THAT SHOWS
THAT THIS KIND OF- A COMMITMENT
FOR THIS VERY LARGE COMMITMENT
OF FUNDING- WE HAVEN'T. SEEN WHY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD MAKE
THIS SUCH A PRIORITY AND INVEST
IN SUCH A WAY BEFORE WE START
GETTING INTO WHAT KINDS OF
CONDITIONS WE WOULD PUT ON IT I
JUST DON'T. SEE IT SO YOU WANT
ONE LAST OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN
THAT I WOULD APPRECIATE IT. JUST
NAMING PARTNER FINANCE AGAIN I
THINK WE JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT YOU KNOW OVERALL ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT CRIMES CAN RESULT
IN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOST.
INCOME FOR RETAILERS AND ANY
ACTIVITIES- AND PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL AGAIN AND PROVIDING
FLEXIBLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR GRAMM
PRO GRAMS ARE TV ATTACHE FIND AS
YOU KNOW IS MISS HOWARD IS
SPECIFIED TO PROBATION
APARTMENTS. FOR CERTAIN THINGS
LIKE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS PERHAPS
DIVERSION FOR NO JUVENILES OR-
FOLKS WHO HAVE DRUG ADDICTIONS
HE MIGHT BE PARTICIPATING IN
THESE ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
CRIMES TO KIND OF ADDRESS
BROADER ROOT PROBLEMS THAT LEAD
TO THESE CRIMES. SO AGAIN WE
JUST WANT TO REITERATE KIND OF
FIT THE INNOVATION AND INTENT.
OF THIS IN BEING A STATEWIDE
EFFORT. OKAY AND I KNOW THERE
WAS A- MIX THERE OF QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS RICK REGARDING-
THEIR ABILITY OUR ABILITY TO
PROSECUTE THEM IT IS ABSOLUTELY
THERE. CAN AND I CAN ARREST AND
CAN'T PROSECUTE SO. THERE IS THE
SON. I BELIEVE A FALSE NARRATIVE
THAT'S GOING AROUND THAT SOMEHOW
WE CAN'T- A PROSECUTE AND- I
TOTALLY DISAGREE WITH THAT. OKAY
WE DO CARE OTHERS NO DOUBT THAT
WE IN THE LEGISLATURE CARE ABOUT
REDUCING CRIME AND THEFT- BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- THIS
PACKAGE WILL TACKLE THE REAL
PRESSING CRIME ISSUES IN THIS
STATE. AND NOT GET CARRIED AWAY
BY WHAT'S GOING ON ON TV- WE
NEED UP I THINK A PLAN THAT'S
MUCH MORE THOUGHTFUL AND CLEAR
AND HAS DATA BACKING IT UP. AND
IT USES REAL- EVIDENCE TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AND IF WE NEED
TO THEN WHAT'S THE CRITERIA SO
WITH THAT. I APPRECIATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY NUMBER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I JUST
WANT TO- WITHOUT GETTING INTO IT
WE COULD DO. Q. AND A WITH
WANTED TO EXPOSE WHISPERS WITH
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM CHP
REGARDING THE FACT THAT
MISDEMEANORS CAN STILL BE
PROSECUTED ON PETTY THEFT OR
INBOUND ON CRUTCHES- UNDER THE
THRESHOLD THAT WAS BEING
DISCUSSED. WHICH WHICH COULD
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO A YEAR IN
JAIL SO IT'S NOT AS IF THERE ARE
PENALTIES OUT THERE AND I JUST.
DIDN'T WANT YOU TO BE ALONE IN
SAYING THAT I WANTED TO- CONFIRM
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR OKAY-
APPRECIATE THANK YOU WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TO. LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GUN BUY BACK PROGRAM
GRANTS- IS THAT YOU MISS HOUR.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO KATIE
HOWARD AGAIN. WE WOUND UP
COVERING A VERY GOOD DEAL OF THE
THINGS I HAD WANTED TO SAY IN
RESPONSE TO. THE AGENDA
QUESTIONS I THOUGHT THE AGENDA
ON THE SIDE AND DID A VERY NICE
JOB OF- LAYING OUT QUESTIONS ON
THE GUN BUY BACK PROGRAMS ON
THERE ARE MIXED REVIEWS. GUN
BUYBACK PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
UNDERTAKEN AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS. LINE OF
QUESTIONING ABOUT WHAT HOW CAN
WE BE SURE THAT IF WE UNDERTAKE
THIS THAT IT WILL MEET- THE
SHARED GOALS OF- YOU KNOW
GETTING GUNS OFF THE STREET AND
EDUCATING YOUNG PEOPLE. ABOUT
GUN VIOLENCE SO. I DID SAY A LOT
OF THESE THINGS BEFORE SO I
WOULD JUST MENTION A COUPLE OF
THINGS THIS IS ALSO NOTED IN
THE- ANALYSIS THAT THE- LA- HAS
PUBLISHED. MORE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT THE GOALS OF A GUN
BUYBACK PROGRAMS. OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO CERTAINLY MAKES SENSE I
THINK IN THIS CONTEXT I THINK
AGAIN YOU KNOW AS OFTEN HAPPENS
IN A JANUARY BUDGET. THE HIGH
LEVEL- CONCEPTS ARE LAID OUT AND
THEN THE DETAILS HAPPEN THROUGH
THIS PROCESS SO WHAT SHOULD THE
SPECIFIC GOALS INCLUDE AND THEN
THE S. WHICH FLOW FROM THAT HOW
THEN WOULD WE- PUT IN- WAYS TO
MEASURE AND ASSESS. WHETHER WE
MET THOSE GOALS- I WOULD HEARKEN
BACK TO THE EXECUTIVE STEERING
COMMITTEE PROCESS THAT I
MENTIONED- THE BORDER STATING TO
MEET ANY CORRECTIONS- BUILDS
GRANTS BY USING- COMMITTEES THAT
ARE. POPULATED BY PEOPLE WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE SO WE
WOULD JUST. GO AFTER THAT THE
QUESTION WOULD BE OKAY WHAT
WOULD A- HIGH QUALITY GUN BUY
BACK PROGRAM LOOKS LIKE AND THEN
THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD. BE ABLE TO
SELL- THIS IS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN. ONE TIME
FUNDING SO YOU KNOW. MANY OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN COMING
THROUGH YOUR COMMITTEE AT NOT
IT'S NOT A HUGE PROGRAM BUT
CERTAINLY. ONE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES CAN MAKE
AN IMPACT. SO I'M I'LL STOP
THERE AND BE TO ANY. YOU MAY.
OKAY THANK YOU WAS HOWARD- FROM
THE LA- ON IS MISSILE. YES- ANY
WITH THE LATEST PANEL OFFICE- AS
WAS REFERENCED- I AM MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER MILLS AT A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF KIND OF
SETTING UP OUR BROADER COMMENTS
RELATED TO THE PACKAGE I'M NOT
GOING TO REPEAT THEM AGAIN- I AM
GOING TO FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
COMMENTS RELATED TO FIREARMS-
AND SO AS REFERENCE TO WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THIS PROGRAM WHICH- WE
DID THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW KIND OF
GUN BUYBACKS CAN BE TARGETED TO
ADDRESS. DIFFERENT PURPOSES SUCH
AS TO REDUCE FIREARM SUICIDE OR
TO REDUCE FIREARM CRIME RELATED
VIOLENCE AND SO IF REDUCING
FIREARM CRIME RELATED VIOLENCE
IS THE GOAL RESEARCH DOES
SUGGEST THAT SUCH PROGRAMS ARE
MORE EFFECTIVE IF THEIR
STRUCTURE IN PARTICULAR WAYS
SUCH AS REQUIRING FIREARMS BE
WORKING IN ORDER TO RECEIVE AN
INCENTIVE. PRIORITIZING THE
TYPES OF FIREARMS THAT ARE USED
IN CRIMES AND ARE FOCUSING ON
THE TYPES OF INDIVIDUALS ARE
LOCATIONS ARE MORE PRONE TO
FIREARM VIOLENCE- AND SO THOSE
ADMITS HOWARD WAS REFERENCING
MIGHT GET WORKED OUT AS PART. OF
THE PROCESS BUT IT'S KIND OF
UNCLEAR WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
WOULD BE INCLUDED AND THESE ARE
KEY THINGS THAT RESEARCH HAS
DEMONSTRATED HAVE BEEN MORE
EFFECTIVE IF YOU. ARE GOING TO
DO A GUN BUYBACK PROGRAM. IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW PRICE. PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS- AND IF YOUR
THINKING ABOUT IT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER-
FIREARM RELATED GOALS AND SO
DATA HAS INDICATED THAT THERE
HS BEEN A GROWTH IN HOMICIDE
FIREARM DEATHS. AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE IN THE SHARE OF
HOMICIDES AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS
AND ROBBERIES. THAT INVOLVED
FIREARMS- ADDITIONALLY YOU KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE HAS HAD
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO THE
STATE'S ARMED AND PROHIBITED
PERSONS LAST. AS OF JAN AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE
ARE ABOUT TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS ON THAT
LIST. THOSE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO-
SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME PROHIBITED
FROM OWNING OR POSSESSING
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITIONS BECAUSE
THEY WERE CONVICTED OF FELONIES
CERTAIN MISDEMEANORS- DOWN BY A
COURT TO BE A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS DUE TO
MENTAL ILLNESS OR HAVE A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST THEM.
AND RESEARCH HAS SUGGESTED THAT
FIREARM. PROHIBITIONS AGAINST
SOME OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD BE ON THIS LIST- CAN.
DECREASE IN THAT CRIME OR
CERTAIN HOMICIDES. SO IN THE
REPORT THAT WE RELEASED WHICH IS
ALSO REFLECTED IN AN INNER JOHN
THAT WE DO OFFER TWO OPTIONS FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION IF
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT. OTHER
KIND OF GOALS AND SO THE FIRST
IS LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL PLANS FOR DOJ'S GUN
VIOLENCE REDUCTION PROGRAM.
WHERE FUNDING WAS PROVIDED TO
COUNTY SHERIFFS TO REDUCE THE
ARMED AND PROHIBITED
PERSONALIZED- AS THE ASSISTANT
DOJ AND KIND OF REMOVING THOSE
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION SO THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
FURTHER REDUCE. THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LIST IT COULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THIS PROGRAMME AND MAKE OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SUCH AS
CITY POLICE ALSO. ELIGIBLE FOR
THE GRANT. A SECOND OPTION IS
ONE JUST. WANTS TO GO. OF THE
LAST- AND THAT WOULD BE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. TO INSURE
THAT FIRE ARMS ARE RELINQUISHED
THE TIME INDIVIDUALS GO THROUGH
THE COURT PROCESS AND- DEAN JUNE
NO LONGER BE ABLE TO- POSSESS
THEM. AND SO THAT WOULD BE
THERE'S A PROCESS LAID OUT UNDER
EXISTNG LAW SO THAT WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IRMA. OKAY SEND A COURTESY
ANY PARTICULAR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. I'M SORRY- I'M SORRY.
OKAY FINANCE A SATURDAY I JUST
MADE A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
I THINK JUST TO REITERATE WHAT
MISS HOWARD SAID AS FAR AS THIS
BEING KIND OF A GENERAL- IDEA
ENTERTAINED ITEM FOR THE-
RESTORATION IS THAT THE GOAL.
BROADLY IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF FIREARMS NOT NECESSARILY
THOSE SPECIFIC. INVOLVED IN
CRIMES- YOU KNOW SUICIDES IN AND
OTHER KIND OF NEGATIVE OUTCOMES
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THE NUMBER
OF FIREARMS IN THIS SOCIETY IN
SO. MANY MINISTRATION BELIEVE
THAT FINDING THIS STATEWIDE
EFFORT WOULD NOT ONLY REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF FIREARMS BOTH THOSE
THAT POTENTIALLY MAY HAVE BEEN
OR POTENTIALLY COULD BE INVOLVED
IN A CRIME BUT JUST DIDN'T JACK.
THE NUMBER OF FIREARMS IN
SOCIETY. IT IS IT WORTHWHILE
EFFORT- WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY AS
MISS WE NOTED INVESTED IN THE
ARMED AND PROHIBITED. PERSONS
SYSTEM- IN NINETEEN THE BUDGET
PROVIDED SEVENTEEN FIVE MILLION
ON GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT-
TEMPLE STERN SUPPORT THAT
PROGRAM- INSTEAD AGAIN THE
ATTENTION OF THIS IS. IS THE
KIND OF COMMENT THE PROBLEM OF
GUN VIOLENCE IN IT AND AT
DIFFERENT CAPTAIN IN A BROADER
STATEWIDE EFFORT TO JUST REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF GUNS AND PROVIDE
KIND OF COMMUNITY OUT REACH AN
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DANGERS.
OF GUN OWNERSHIP IN GENERAL- AS
WELL AS IN OUR OTHER BUDGET
PROPOSALS- INCLUDING THE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO.
IMPLEMENT ANY KIND OF CONDUCT
ADDITIONAL GUN RESEARCH WE
THOUGHT THAT COMING AT THIS
ISSUE FROM AS MANY ANGLES AS
POSSIBLE. WOULD PRODUCE
BENEFICIAL OUTCOMES. OKAY FROM
MR CRITICIZING. THANK YOU
VENTURE- HI I JUST WANTED TO SAY
A COUPLE THINGS- WITH REGARD TO
THE ITEM ONE IS I AGREE THAT-
YOU KNOW POOR PROGRAM DESIGN IS
CAN BE A PROBLEM OR AT A MINIMUM
POOR PROGRAM DESIGN CAN CAN MAKE
. THE EFFORT A LOT LAST.
SUCCESSFUL IN TERMS OF AFFECTED
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW WHAT
OFTENTIMES LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND MENTAL HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
ARE REALLY TRYING TO TARGET. IN
YOU KNOW I THINK IT WOULD BE.
PRUDENT EVEN THOUGH I AM
UNDERSTANDING THAT INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION KIND OF WANT TO
STAY AT. THIRTY THOUSAND FEET
AND GOT THE IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS FOR LATER. YOU KNOW BUT
TO TALK ABOUT IT YOU KNOW IN THE
BUDGET ITEM THE FACT THAT. THE
DEAD THESE PROGRAMS NEED TO BE
TIED TO COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT- MY
EXPERIENCE AND I'M I'M GUESSING
THE SENATOR ALSO AND I NEVER
TALKED ABOUT THIS BUT BASED ON
HER BOOK HER BACKGROUND LOS
ANGELES. A MINE IN PLACES LIKE
HE SETTLES A- WE'VE HAD
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS WITH THESE
KIND OF PROGRAMS WHEN WE TIED
THEM. BUT TWO THINGS LIKE GANG
ABATEMENT ACTIVITIES WHEN WE
HAD. BUT YOUNG PEOPLE OR
ORGANIZATIONS- LIKE YOU'D SEE
I'M IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH
HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES AND FOLKS
LIKE THAT WHO ARE ACTUALLY GOING
OUT. HI- DOOR TO DOOR URGING
PEOPLE TO GET RID OF UNWANTED
GUNS IN NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE.
THEY'RE JUST WAY OVER
REPRESENTED ON A PER HOUSEHOLD
BASIS IN IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE THERE IS A MORE
SIGNIFICANT CRIME ELEMENTS- IN
AN OFFICE HE CAN DO THE SAME
THING AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES BY. BY VIRTUE OF
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT TWO THIRDS
ON A REGULAR BASIS TWO THIRDS OF
WHAT- BUT THE DESKTOP REPORTED
BY OUR CORE CORNER PULLED ASIDE
- ARE SELF INFLICTED IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY MONTH AFTER MONTH
AFTER MONTH TWO THIRDS SOUL- YOU
KNOW THE TICKET IT DOESN'T TAKE
. A LOT OF EXTRA LANGUAGE I
DON'T THINK TWO TO TIE. THESE
BUDGET ITEMS TO THOSE KIND OF
TARGETS THAT YOU WANT TO SEE THE
LOCALS ACTUALLY. FOCUS ON
BECAUSE THERE IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN DOING THAT IN
TRYING TO SORT OF TAKE BACK. OR
MAKE SAFER NEIGHBORHOODS- VERSUS
JUST THE RETAIL OPERATION WHICH
I'VE ALSO SEEN WHERE THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT SAYS FROM NINE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING UNTIL TWO
IN THE AFTERNOON ANYONE CAN
DRIVE THROUGH. AND GET RID OF
THEIR OLD HUNTING RIFLE FOR A
HUNDRED DOLLARS. HERE IN AND I'M
JUST NOT SURE IT IN MOST CASES
IT'S REALLY ACCOMPLISHING THE
SAME KIND OF A GOAL SO. THOSE
ARE THAT'S MY TWO CENTS ON THE
INVESTMENT IT IT'S PROBABLY TO
THE FINANCE SO. IT WAS A FINANCE
OFFICE WHO SAID. IN SO MANY
WORDS IT'S HARD TO MAKEA
MISTAKE GETTING GUNS OFF THE
STREET SO- PERHAPS THERE IS AN
ARGUMENT THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
TARGETED DEMOGRAPHICS WHEN
YOU'RE GONE DOING THIS ONE IS A
DEMOGRAPHIC SO WE REALLY MEAN
GEOGRAPHIC SOMETIMES BUT I DO
THINK AGAIN IT'S A LOT MORE
EFFECTIVE WHEN YOU DO SO. I
COMMEND HER THANK YOU SENATOR I
THINK YOU RAISE A REALLY
POWERFUL POINT WHICH IS COMING
COMING TO US AND REQUESTING
MONEY FOR THE BUY BACK GUNS.
DOESN'T ISN'T THE PICTURE THAT
WE NEED A COMPLETE PICTURE OF
WHAT'S GONNA TAKE PLACE THAT
THIS IS A PART OF SOMETHING
ELSE. IT'S A PART OF WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY BUT NOT JUST
TELLING THE COMMUNITY THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO A REALLY
ENGAGING WITH THEM IN SUCH A WAY
THAT YOU HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO GETTING THOSE GUNS
OFF THE STREETS- IT'S NOT THE
SAME AS YOU KNOW DOING A QUOTE
UNQUOTE PUBLIC AWARENESS. OF OUR
KIND OF CAMPAIGN THAT'S NOT THE
PROBLEM THE PROBLEM IS HAVING-
COMMUNITY LEADERS. TELL US HOW
TO ADDRESS IT AND WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENT PIECES THAT WORK FOR
US THERE SO I THINK THAT'S THE
FOR ME AND I APPRECIATE SENATOR
CORTEZ THESE COMMENTS IS UP
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A REAL
SOLUTION NOT JUST THE PIECEMEAL.
HERE AND THERE ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT INVOLVES- SO MUCH MONEY- AND
WE KNOW THAT BY THEMSELVES YOU
KNOW THESE BUY BACK PROGRAMS ARE
NOT EFFECTIVE- AND- YEAH WE WILL
TRY A LOT OF THINGS BUT- AFTER A
WHILE THIS IS BEEN GOING ON THE
COMMUNITIES FOR. MANY YEARS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
KNOW. WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T WORK. SO WITH THAT
APPRECIATE- THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH- WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUES THREE. FIREARMS TRACKING
AND DATA SYSTEMS AND I BELIEVE
THE DOJ'S OFFICE. IS THAT MISS
HARPER. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR ASHLEY HART BUDGET
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE-
THE FIREARMS PROPOSALS OUTLINED
IN THIS AGENDA ITEM SEEK THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
AND MAINTAIN THE MANDATES OF
THREE LEGISLATIVE BILLS SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN. AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
AND EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
ADDITIONALLY DOJ REQUEST
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE THE
CURRENT FIRE ARMS IT
MODERNIZATION EFFORT WHICH WILL
PROVIDE FOR A LONG TERM MODERN
IT SOLUTION TO MEET EXISTING
BUSINESS NEEDS AND TO ADDRESS
CURRENT AND FUTURE STATUTORY
MANDATES IN A MORE COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER. I AS WELL AS
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE DIVISION
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INFORMATION
SERVICES DIVISION ARE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
WHEN THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE ON
THESE PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MARK FURMAN. YOU OKAY AND OF
THE LA- ANY DELAY AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS OF THE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. OKAY FOR
THE COURTESY AND THE REMARKS ON
THIS ISSUE THOUGH THIS WAS
PRETTY CLEAR FOR ME THANK OKAY.
GREAT THANK YOU. SHARE THAT WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE CAN MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUE FOR WHICH IS OUR TASK
FORCE ON A PROGRAM. AND WE'LL
HAVE THE DOJ START OFF. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ASHLEY HARP
AGAIN BUDGET OFFICER AT DOJ- DOJ
REQUESTS AN INCREASE IN GENERAL
FUND AUTHORITY OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND I'M GOING TO MAINTAIN
DOJ OVERSIGHT AND PARTICIPATION
IN COLLABORATIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TASK FORCE'S
STATEWIDE AT THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED PARTICIPATION IN EIGHT
TASK FORCES WHICH ACT AS
COLLABORATIVE PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERSHIPS BY UTILIZING
PERSONNEL FROM VARIOUS LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES TO
FORM TEAMS TO CONDUCT CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND ENFORCEMENT
AIDING AGENCIES IN OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY EFFORTS. AT THIS REQUEST
SEEKS THE STATE SHARE OF COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PARTICIPATING IN
A TASK FORCES WHICH WILL PROVIDE
FOR A MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
PERMANENT COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING THESE COMPLEX MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL INVESTIGATIONS
THAT HAVE BOTH REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE BENEFITS. I WITHOUT
WELCOME QUESTION- FROM YOURSELF
OR THE COMMITTEE ON THIS AGENDA
ITEM. OKAY WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF NC DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. PART OF MY HANDS NO
COMMENTS THANK YOU. OKAY AND-
MISLI THE LA OFFICE. S. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO AS MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER O'NEILL
MENTIONS- THIS IS ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT WE EVALUATED AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S PUBLIC
SAFETY PLAN- WE DID IN OUR
REVIEW- I RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER APPROVING
MASS AS IT WOULD MAINTAIN DOJ'S
PARTICIPATION OF TASK FORCES TO
DEAL WITH THESE COMPLEX AND
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL.
INVESTIGATIONS THAT COULD HAVE
BOTH STATEWIDE AND REGIONAL
REGIONAL BENEFITS THIS IS REALLY
BECAUSE EACH OF THE
PARTICIPATING AGENCIES IS PAYING
FOR THE COSTS OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING- AND THIS
REALLY PROVIDES INCENTIVE TO
ENSURE THAT EACH TASK FORCE IS
FOCUSING ON INVESTIGATING THOSE
CRIMES THAT ARE OF THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY ALL OF THE
PARTICIPATING MEMBERS WHICH ARE
GENERALLY THOSE THAT ARE THE
MOST PRESSING ENTER THE MOST
COMPLEX. AND CERTAINLY WITH THAT
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT YOUR
HIGHEST PUBLIC SAFETY PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT WERE-
THINGS LIKE RETAIL FAST OR YOU
KNOW PARTICULAR INCREASES IN
CRIME- OUTSIDE OF RETAILFAST.
AND SO SOME OF THAT MIGHT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE THINKS THAT THAT'S A
PRIORITY TO ADDRESS THAT
INEQUITY IT COULD ACTUALLY EVEN
CONSIDER EXPANDING. THESE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY OPERATE
REGIONALLY AND SO WHAT YOU COULD
GET- IS THAT YOU CAN HAVE ONE
FOR SOME PARTICIPANTS WORKING
TOGETHER- POOLING THEIR
RESOURCES AND MAKING USE OF THAT
PARTICULAR SKILL SETS THAT EACH
OF THEM HAVE. AND SO THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD ALSO HAVE
INCENTIVE TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
OF THOSE CRIMES BEING
INVESTIGATED ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTING THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
THE STATE ALSO BENEFITS BECAUSE
THE STATE'S NOT BEARING THE FULL
COST. OF KIND OF DEALING WITH
THAT AND SO THOSE ARE JUST A
COUPLE BLOCKS. AND WE'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY- C.
OKAY MONSON OCCURRED HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS FILE FOR THE DOJ'S
OFFICE IS- HOW DO YOU DECIDE
WHICH TASK FORCES TO PARTICIPATE
AND- AND OUR- FOR THEIR NEW OR
ADDITIONAL TASK FORCES ARE
REGIONS THAT SHOULD BE INCLUDED-
AND ALSO. WHEN AND HOW DO YOU
DECIDE THAT IT'S- NO LONGER
NEEDED TO HAVE A TASK FORCE HOW
ODD IS THAT DECISION MADE MADE-
GET MADE I NOTICED IN THE
DESCRIPTION OF THESE TASK FORCES
AT SOME GO BACK AS FAR AS
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE. NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE. NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN FOR
VERY SPECIFIC GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS
SO. FIRST OF ALL JUST MAKING THE
DECISION THAT HAVE A TASK FORCE
I THINK THAT'S I MEAN HAVING THE
TASK FORCE I'M SURE HOW IS A
GOOD THING. TO HAVE THAT
COORDINATION BUT- OF- HOW DO YOU
STARTED IN. HOW DO YOU ENDED
WHEN DO YOU AND HOW DO YOU MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION OF MADAM CHAIR I
HAVE JOHN MARSH WHO IS OUR CHIEF
OF THE DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AVAILABLE TO SPEAK
TO THOSE QUESTIONS. SURE THANK
YOU. FOR THAT QUESTION-
STARTING- WE WORK WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES AND IDENTIFY. ISSUES IN
LOCAL AREAS AND- KIND OF MEL THE
TASK FORCES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY. INTERESTING WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE DATES OF
STARTING UP THE DIFFERENT TASK
FORCES. BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT A
MONTH. FIFTY NINE STATEWIDE AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DIDN'T GET TO
MAKE THE DECISION- I'M CLOSING
THEM IT WAS A FUNDING ISSUE AND
OF THE STATE CUT OUR BUDGET AND
WE HAD TO CLOSE UP FORTY OR AT
THE TIME THIRTY FIVE TASK FORCES
. WE'RE DOWN TO EIGHT THAT- ARE
THE MOST. TESTING RIGHT NOW- AS
YOU YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
TASK FORCE'S ALLEY IMPACT IS THE
LARGEST- TASK FORCE IN THE
NATION COVERS THE ENTIRE- LOS
ANGELES AREA. WITH FORTY
DIFFERENT AGENCIES PARTICIPATING
AT- TO A LOCAL- TASK FORCE-
IMPOSTER COUNTY. AND THAT HAS
SIX PARTICIPATING AGENCIES ON IT
BUT THEY SERVE- THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITY IN THE NEEDS THAT THEY
HAVE AND IT'S A FORCE
MULTIPLIER. EACH PASSWORD HAS
EACH TASK FORCE HAS A BOARD. AND
THE BOARD- COMES TOGETHERNESS-
POLICE CHIEFS AND SHARP SCENT.
WE COME UP WITH WHAT ARE THE
PRESSING ISSUES AND FOCUS ON
THOSE ISSUES IN THEIR AREA- TO
PROVIDE- EXPERT- INVESTIGATIVE
ASSISTANCE- THE PART THE DOJ
COMES AND WE HAVE STATE WIDE
CONNECTIVITY. SO OUR TASK FORCES
ARE CONNECTED A STATEWIDE AND
ALSO THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES OF
DOJ'S SO FOR THE INSTANCE THAT I
GIVE UP IMPOSTER- THEY HAVE A
CASE WHERE. YOU KNOW THAT THE
PEOPLE ARE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CONNECT TO
THEM EITHER WITH OUR FIELD
OFFICES FOR OUR TASK FORCES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- TO EVEN-
BOLSTER- THEIR INVESTIGATIVE
CAPACITY. SO OTHER QUESTION
ABOUT EXPANDING TASK FORCES WE
WOULD LOVE TO- EXPAND OUR TASK
FORCE CAPACITY AND THAT WOULD
BE- AN AREA BY AREA WE WORK WITH
LOCAL SHERIFFS AND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS- JUST SEE. A LEVEL
OF THEIR ENGAGEMENT IN AREAS. SO
JUST AS A FOLLOW UP TO WHAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED- THE EXPANSION OF
OUR VIEW. OF. I'M SURE YOU'VE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT BUT HOW WOULD
YOU GO FORWARD IN- HUSSEIN
STATEWIDE UP HERE'S THE STRATEGY
STATEWIDE THIS IS WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO DO OF COURSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THE BUY IN AND ON THE ON THE
SUPPORT AND THE MOTIVATION AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT HOW DO YOU
LOOK AT ME LOOK AT THIS OR HOW
DO YOU LOOK AT THIS IN A MORE
STRATEGIC- STATEWIDE- BASIS.
YEAH HI TESSA QUESTIONS SO-
THAT'S WHAT DOJ DOES WELL IS
CONNECTING STATE- BUT BUT THE
NEW ONES THAT MAKES THESE TASK
FORCES SO SUCCESSFUL. IS THEY
ARE INDEPENDENT- DOJ COMES IN IT
CONNECTS THE TASK FORCE'S
TOGETHER BUT EACH TASK FORCE
WORKS INDEPENDENTLY. ON
INDEPENDENT ISSUES WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SO IT IT REALLY IS
A- COMMUNITY BASED TYPE
ENFORCEMENT. ACTION SO AT ONE
TIME MOST OF OUR TASK FORCES
WERE NOT PRODUCT BASED AND AS
THE TRENDS OF A NARCOTIC
ENFORCEMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT SHIFT. THEN THE
TASK FORCE'S SHIFTED THEIR FOCUS
AT MOST OF OUR TASK FORCES ARE
SPECIAL OPERATIONS TEAMS AND
THEY THEY FOCUSED ON WHATEVER
THE COMMUNITY ISSUE IS AND
BRING- INVESTIGATIVE EXPERIENCE-
TO THAT AREA. OKAY ALL RIGHT
WHAT THE PRE SHAPE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
RESPONSES- AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FIVE OF WHICH IS COVERS
VARIOUS LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
AND AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IF YOU WOULD PRESENT. I
THINK YOU KNOW- ACTUALLY HEART
BUDGET OFFICER DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- UNDER THIS AGENDA ITEM
DOJ REQUEST RESOURCE AS
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THE
MANDATED WORKLOADS OF TWELVE
LEGISLATIVE BELLS. RESOURCE AS
WELL ALLOW DOJ TO IMPLEMENT AND
MAINTAIN THE NECESSARY CHANGES
IN WORK LOAD AND THAT'S DRIVEN
BY THESE BILLS- THERE ARE A
TOTAL OF THREE PROPOSALS THAT
ARE TE RESULT OF LEGISLATION
PASSED IN PREVIOUS SESSIONS AND-
THE REMAINING THE REMAINING
PROPOSALS ARE THE RESULT OF
LEGISLATION. THAT WAS RECENTLY
PASSED AND WE WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS THAT. YOU OR THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ON THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE HAVE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
COMMENT PLEASE. A FORMER FINANCE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME. OKAY
AND- LA O'S OFFICE PLEASE. I
NEED TO LEAVE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IF THEY HAVE NO
CONCERNS- RELATED TO THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
COURTESY AND THE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS CLICK TO SUBSCRIBE TO
SEE THE PASS LEGISLATION BEING
FUNDED. THAT'S IT. HAVE BEEN
FLAGGED BY THE SAME THING TO
EFFECTIVELY RIGHT. OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
SIX. THE SPECIAL FUND. A SPECIAL
FUND CONDITIONS AND- GO BACK TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
HARP. HI ASHLEY HARP D. O. J.
UNDER THIS AGENDA ITEM DOJ
REQUEST AT TWO THINGS ONE IS
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
IF NEEDED TO THE AMMUNITION ST
DAN FORSMAN SPECIAL FUND WHICH
SUPPORTS THE DOJ'S AMMUNITION
PURCHASED AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM.
DUE TO INSUFFICIENT REVENUES TO
THE FIND AND NUMBER TWO REQUEST
A GENERAL FUND BACK FILL OF THE
DNA ID FIND OF FORTY SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION ON A ONE TIME BASIS
WHICH SUPPORTS DOJ'S BUREAU
FORENSIC SERVICES AND
PROVISIONAL ENGLISH FOR
ADDITIONAL GENERAL GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT IF NEEDED- I'M AVAILABLE
AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES AND-
THE- GIRLFRIENDS EX. SERVICES
AND THAT- OUR ARMS TO DRESSING
THAT YOU HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLEASE.
MARTIN IS A COMMON FINANCE WITH
REGARDS TO INDIANS BECAUSE OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE THE
AMMUNITION TRANSACTION WE JUST
FELT THAT WE USE FOR- THE
AMMUNITION- FINE HAVE BEEN BALL
TILE AND HAVE NOT ESTABLISHED A
BASELINE PATTERNS SO DIFFICULT
TO DETERMINE. THE STRUCTURE AT
THIS TIME ALSO YOU KNOW BE THE
THOUGHT IS THAT PROVIDING ON THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO BACKFILL
PLAN WOULD ALLOW- S. ALLOW DOJ
TO MAINTAIN CURRENT SERVICE
LEVELS- AS WE DETERMINED. NOT
REQUIRING SOLUTION. I THANK YOU
. OVER M. THE ELLY ELLS OFFICE
MISLI. HE MANAGED CARE- WE DO
HAVE COMMENTS FOR YOU ON BOTH
SPECIAL PLANS FOR YOU IS THE
FIRST ONE FOCUSED ON THE
AMMUNITION SAFETY AND
ENFORCEMENT FRIENDS- WE FIRST
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MODIFY THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE ANY GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES TO THIS SPECIAL
PLANNED AS A LOAN SH AND THIS
WOULD BE SIMILAR TO THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR START AT ONE
THAT WAS AUTHORIZED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. BY PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE AND ASK ME TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE WHICH ALSO CREATED
THAT'S FINE- WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES COULD
BE NEEDED IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO
ENSURE THAT THE AMMUNITION
PURCHASE AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM
SERVICE LEVELS ARE MAINTAINED.
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION- IS WE
DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CHANGE STATE LAW TO
INCREASE THE AMMUNITION PURCHASE
TRANSACTION FEE. THIS IS EXACTLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE ONE
THAT'S CURRENTLY ONE DOLLAR. PER
TRANSACTION- THE INTENSIVE
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE AND
ACTUALLY TWELVE THIRTY FIVE WAS
FOR FEE REVENUES TO COVER THE
STATE'S REASONABLE REGULATORY
AND ENFORCEMENT COSTS. RELATED
TO AMMUNITION PURCHASES AND SO-
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FIGURE BEFORE
YOU ON PAGE TWENTY SIX- A FEE
INCREASE WILL BE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE FINES- OPERATIONAL
SHORTFALL WHICH HAS EXISTED
SINCE THE FUND. HAS BEEN CREATED
AS WELL AS TO START REPAYING
THAT GENERAL PLAN START UP WELL.
WE WOULDN'T KOW THAT IF THE
INCREASE WOULD REQUIRE. A 55%
APPROVAL BY EACH HOUSE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE. WHEN
THINKING ABOUT THAT FEE INCREASE
THE LEGISLATURE HAS VARIOUS
OPTIONS THAT THEY COULD
CONSIDER. SUCH AS- AND- AS ARE
THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW VARIOUS
FACTORS INCLUDING THE MAXIMUM
PER TRANSACTION FEES DESIRED HOW
QUICKLY THEY WANT THE GENERAL
PLANS START AT ONCE TO BE
REPAID. AND WHEN THE DESIRE TO
SEE INCREASED SHOULD TAKE A
FACT. SO FOR EXAMPLE- ASSUMING
LITTLE CHANGING PURCHASER
BEHAVIOR- INCREASING THE FEE BY
TWO DOLLARS SO FOR A TOTAL THREE
DOLLARS EACH THAT COULD
BASICALLY HELP ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDS OPERATIONAL SHORTFALL WAS
ADDRESSED AND DEAL WITH KIND OF
MINOR CHANGES IN REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES. AN ADDITIONAL ONE
DOLLAR INCREASE FOR A TOTAL OF
FOUR DOLLAR FEET THAT COULD
ACTUALLY GENERATE SUFFICIENT
REVENUES TO RETAIN THE GENERAL
FUND LONG WITHIN THE NEXT
FIFTEEN YEARS. SO THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT CAN BE WAIT. RELATED
THE DNA I DON'T. FINDS WE HAVE
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
THAT- WE WOULD NOTE FOR THE
COMMITTEE THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY
ONE OF THE STATE'S SPECIAL PLANS
THAT IS IMPACTED BY DECLINING
COLONEL FINANCE DEPARTMENT.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT IN
PRIOR EXPERIENCES WE JUST WANTED
TO FIND. OUT SO FIRST WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PORSCHE PARTIALLY SUPPORT THE
BUREAU FORENSIC SERVICES.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AM PROVIDE DOJ WITH
DIRECTION ON HOW MUCH OF ITS
OPERATIONS SHOULD COME FROM
LOCAL AGENCIES SUCH AS LIKE ONE
THIRD OR ONE HALF. AND THIS
COULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUND NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE BFS COST ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. IN THE AGENDA BEFORE YOU
ON PAGE TWENTY SEVEN YOU HAVE A
GOOD CHART SHOWS BASICALLY THE
GENERAL PLAN BACK FILL THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED. IN RECENT YEARS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT IT'S KIND
OF INCREASING- WOULD ALSO THAT
THIS RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
MORE EQUITABLE THAN THE EXISTING
SYSTEM IN WHICH CERTAIN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE RECEIVING
SERVICES AT NO CHARGE WHILE
OTHERS ARE PAYING TO OPERATE
THEIR OWN LABORATORIES. AND SO
WITH AGENCIES THAT THEN RECEIVE
SERVICES BEING REQUIRED TO PAY
FOR A PORTION OF IT ACTUALLY
PROVIDES A GREATER INCENTIVE FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES TO PRIORITIZE.
THE WORK OF THAT THEY'RE SENDING
TO DOJ AS WELL. D. O. J. WOULD
HAVE FLEXIBILITY AND CALCULATING
EACH LOCAL AGENCIES SHARE TO
DEAL WITH EQUITY ISSUES AND
OTHER CONCERNS. AND THAT COULD
INCLUDE YOU KNOW HAVING AGENCIES
CAME MORE OR LESS BASED ON THE
SPECIFIC TYPE OF FORENSIC
SERVICES SOUGHT. THE SPEED OF
THE SERVICE OR THE SIZE OF THE
AGENCY. THE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE WOULD
PROVIDE TIME FOR FOLKS TO ADAPT
TO THE NEW FUNDING STRUCTURE AND
ALLOW FOR IT TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
IN LINE WITH THIS OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AS PART OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET- IS REQUIRING DOJ
REPORT- BY MARCH ON- OPTIONS
OTHER THAN THE GENERAL PLAN TO
SUPPORT BE A FAST AND ONE OF THE
OPTIONS WAS TO INCLUDE- WIND
RELATED TO SHARING COSTS WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES AND THAT.
INFORMATION COULD THEN BE USED
TO INFORM THIS NEW FUNDING
STRUCTURE. THE FINAL
RECOMMENDATION IS WE DO
RECOMMEND APPROVING THIS
PROPOSAL. JUST FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR TO ENSURE THAT SERVICE
LEVELS ARE MAINTAINED WHILE THIS
NEW FUNDING STRUCTURE THAT WE
RECOMMEND- IT IS IMPLEMENTED AND
ALLOW FOR DOJ AND LOCAL AGENCIES
AND GOVERNMENTS TO ADAPT TO THE
NEW. STRUCTURE THANK YOU SO MUCH
. GREAT SOAKED SO ON THE OF- FOR
THE L. A MAN- EITHER THE DOJ OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHAT
IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S. LONG
TERM PLAN FOR DEALING WITH THESE
INSOLVENCY ISSUES. IN BOTH FUNDS. OUR MARKET AS A PERMANENT
FINANCE TOM YOU KNOW CURRENTLY-
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE CONTINUING
TO MONITOR THE CONDITIONS OF THE
FINES AND- AS- B. ELLIE I'VE
NOTED- THE- DOJ WILL BE-
PUBLISHING IT ON MARCH REPORT ON
DNA ID FIND AND OPTIONS I MEAN
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING- YOU
HAVE APARTMENT. WHAT OPTIONS ARE
AVAILABLE- AND AS FAR AS B. B.
B. I MEAN THEY'RE SAYING THAT-
SPECIAL FINE. YEAH IT'S REALLY
HARD TO. SAY- YOU KNOWREALLY
DETERMINE WHAT THE ONGOING
SOLUTION IS UNTIL WE REALLY HAVE
A BETTER SENSE OF ME- B. B. S.
THE REVENUE BASELINE IT'S REALLY
IT IT'S QUITE VOLATILE ON IT AND
IF ANYTHING IT'S AN INCREASING
TREND GOING TO END. WITH IS
THERE THERE CERTAINLY ARE OTHER
ECONOMIC FACTORS THAT ARE OURS
POSSIBLY A PLAY AND SO YOU. KNOW
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE ARE.
THE TWO MONITORS SHORT. NOTES
WERE WORSE MONITOR THE BOTH
FINES AND WE LOOK TO BY THANK
YOU THROUGH AN OFFERING OPTION
FOR ITS ON GOING. THANK YOU.
OKAY SO IT REALLY I MEAN
MONITORING IS FINE BUT YOU
REALLY HAVE TO COME UP WITH A
PLAN SOONER THAN LATER OTHERWISE
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP FACING THIS
YEAR AFTER YEAR- AND I ASSUME-
MISTER YOU MENACE THAT- YOU ARE
ALSO OPEN TO WITH THE LA PHIL'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE. YOU KNOW
WE'RE HAPPY TO YOU KNOW DISCUSS
OUR OPTIONS WITH THE ELIA AND
YOUR STAFF. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
CRITICIZING ANY QUESTIONS. THIS
IS JUST A GENERAL QUESTION AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
. RESIN IN THE MEETING THAT. CAN
ANSWER THIS ONE- IT'S- OF COURSE
IN DIRECTLY RELATED TO IT- THE
BUDGET REQUEST ITSELF BUT ON THE
AMMUNITION SAFETY ENFORCES
SPECIAL FUND- PHARMACY THE STATE
OPERATED. FOR YEARS AND YEARS
WITHOUT SUCH A FUND IN THE FIRST
PLACE I DON'T KNOW THE GRAPHING
HERE GOES BACK TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
I DON'T REMEMBER WHEN IT WAS-
ORIGINALLY LEGISLATED INTO
EXISTENCE BUT- HAS THERE BEEN
ANY SEPARATE AND APART FROM
JUSTICE FOR ACTUATING. THE
PROBLEM WITH- WITH COST RECOVERY
IS SERBIAN ANY AUDIT OR STUDY OF
THE PROGRAM IN TERMS OF ITS
EFFECTIVENESS- THE DATE I GUESS
THAT'S THE QUESTION IS IF
AFFECTED MOSTLY CONSUMER WAS.
INTENDED THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT
WAS TO KEEP. THE WRONG PEOPLE
FROM GETTING AMMUNITION IN THE
FIRST PLACE BUT- IF IT MADE IT
MAY MAKE SOME SENSE OF SOMETHING
FOR US TO HAVE A FEEL FOR
WHETHER OR NOT TO PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY WORKING. I WOULD LIKE
TO WITH TWO DAYS OF THIS. HI I
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION- THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM-
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AS A RESULT OF PROP
SIXTY THREE AND A TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE- DO YOU THIS WORKLOAD WAS
NOT PREVIOUSLY TRACT- SO EARLIER
ESTIMATES WERE SIMPLY- BASED ON
OUR ESTIMATES OF WHAT WE BELIEVE
THAT THOSE TRANSACTIONS WOULD
BE- NOW THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS- WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT THE
COST OF THE PROGRAM
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND REVENUES HAVE BEEN.
ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY- THE OPERATIONAL COSTS
ARE SIMPLY EXCEEDING THE ONE
DOLLAR FEE REVENUES THAT ARE
COMING IN- AND A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL REVENUE EXISTS TO
SUPPORT THE COST OF THE PROGRAM
WE'RE DEFINITELY OPEN TO WORKING
WITH THE ALLEY- AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. FOR AN ONGOING
SOLUTION FOR THIS PROGRAM-
PRECIADO MISS HARPER AND I AND
I'M NOT. I'M I'M BUYING IN
COMPLETELY INTO THE IDEA THAT-
IT'S BEEN HARD TO. FIGURE OUT
THE REVENUE TREND HERE VERSUS
EXPENSES- I GUESS I WAS ASKING
KIND OF A LARGER QUESTION WHICH
WOULD. REQUIRE WORK BY THE LA-
OR SOME SORT OF SOME SORT OF
ANALYSIS OR AUDIT WHICH IS
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WORTH OF
CRIME PREVENTION ACTUALLY
HAPPENING WITH THE PROGRAM- IN A
IN A DO UNDERSTAND. THE GENESIS
OF PROGRAM WASN'T. HI DOJ- HAS
YOU JUST EXPLAINED- YEAH GOOD.
HI I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT THAT
ABOUT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAM MUCH OF MUCH LIKE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS EARLIER TODAY SO I
THANK YOU FOR. YOUR ANSWER
THOUGH AND- I CAN FOLLOW UP ON
THAT. OFFLINE AS SIMPLY. SHOOT.
WELL MAYBE- THE DOJ'S OFFICE
CAN. OFFER SOME IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN PUT
TOGETHER IN THE PAST- RESPONDING
TO SENATOR CORTESE'S OFFICE MISS
HARPER. WE HAVE NOT CONDUCTED A
STUDY OF THE PROGRAM AS OF RIGHT
NOW BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THAT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE I'M SURE TO STUDY
BE PURSUED. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ALL- WE MOVE ON
TO ISSUE SEVEN- WHICH COVERS. IT
SEES THAT THE- PICTURE
DEPARTMENT OF. YES OUR OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES HELLO YES-
THAT'S ISSUE SEVEN. AND WE ARE
ISSUE SEVEN IS ABOUT VARIOUS
STAFFING PROPOSALS SO WE COULD
HAVE. SEE WHO'S. OKAY THE
AVERAGE A DIRECTOR AFTERNOON GET
OUT OF JURY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON.
PARKING ARTESIAN DIRECTOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE WITH YOU TODAY I JUST WANT
TO START OFF WITH- HIGHLIGHTING
THE ROLE OF A WE ASK HOW WE S.
SERVES AS YOUR STATE'S
LEADERSHIP COBB DURING ALL MAJOR
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS. THIS
INCLUDES RESPONDING DIRECTING
AND COORDINATING STATE AND
FEDERAL RESOURCES AND MUTUAL AID
ASSETS ACROSS ALL REGIONS OF THE
STATE TO SUPPORT OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES- AND DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS- AND
OF COURSE HE'S EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS HAVE BECOME. FAR MORE
FREQUENT AND COMPLICATED OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND MY
OFFICE HAS LITERALLY EXPANDED.
TO ADDRESS THESE EVENTS- THE
BETTER AND MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY- AS AS THEY'VE COME
OUT OF US- SO TODAY- THE FIRST
GALLO YES AGAIN THE ITEM BEFORE
YOU IS A BUNDLE OF PROPOSALS
DESIGNED TO STRENGTHEN OUR
PREPAREDNESS PREVENTION
CAPABILITIES AS WELL AS OUR
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
CAPABILITIES FROM ALL HAZARDS.
DISASTERS AND EMERGENCIES IT'S
ALL JUST RUN THROUGH THESE THESE
BUNDLES QUICKLY AND THEN- WHAT
HAD HAPPENED ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS. THE FIRST IS ABOUT
STRENGTHENING OUR REGIONAL
RESPONSE THIS IS A BUDGET
PROPOSAL FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION- AND TWENTY POSITIONS TO
EXPAND CAL- YES IS REGIONAL
RESPONSE CAPACITY AND STRENGTHEN
PARTNERSHIPS IN ENGAGEMENTS WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
STAKEHOLDERS. THESE PROFESSIONAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PERSONNEL
ARE THE FOLKS ON THE GROUND IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES WORKING WITH
YOUR LOCAL EMERGENCY SERVICES
TEAMS CITY AND COUNTY LEADERSHIP
CBO'S NGOS FAITH BASED GROUPS
EXCEPT FOR US AND OUR SCHOOLS
ARE DURING EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS- GIVEN THE SCOPE. GAIL
AND COMPLY OF THIS TODAY THERE
IS A CRITICAL TO X. THESE
REGIONAL. PERSONNEL TO MEET THE
NEEDS PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE
OFTEN OVERLAPPING NATURE OF
DISASTERS THAT WE ARE SEEING
EXPANDING GEOGRAPHICALLY BROADLY
ACROSS. MOST OF TIME MULTIPLE
REGIONS OF THE STATE AT THE SAME
TIME. SOTHAT'S THE FIRST ONE IN
THE BUNDLE THE SECOND IS-
IMPLEMENTING- ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTY. DISCOVERY REQUESTS IS UP
A BUDGET PROPOSAL OF ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION AND SIX POSITIONS
TO COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS AND
ULTIMATELY REVIEW COUNTY
EMERGENCY PLANS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE CONSISTENT WITH. THE
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS BEST
PRACTICES IN LINE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED IN EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY.
THE THIRD IS- INCREASING SUPPORT
CAPACITY- THE BUDGET PROPOSES
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS AT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND SPECIAL
FUNDS. FOR SEVENTY ONE POSITIONS
TO INCREASE ADMINISTRATIVE AND
PROGRAM SUPPORT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. THIS IS REALLY A
TRUE UP OF CRITICAL AND
NECESSARY POSITIONS THAT PROVIDE
CAPACITY CONTINUITY AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ACROSS THE
AGENCY THESE POSITIONS INCLUDE
SPECIALISTS IN OUR FINANCIAL
OPERATIONS A LOT OF TEEN LEGAL
OFFICE COMMUNICATIONS. S.
RESPONSE SUPPORT SECTIONS OVER
THE YEARS AS A DEPARTMENT AND
ITS RESPONSIBILITY HAVE EXPANDED
AND AS SUCH SO HAS THAT
TREMENDOUS WORK LOAD AT A
REQUIREMENT AT ALL OF THESE
AREAS FOR THE CONTINUITY OF
OPERATIONS AND THE LAST IN THIS
BUNDLE IS ADDRESSING LOGISTICS
MANAGEMENT WORKLOAD. THIS IS A
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION GENERAL FINE AND TWENTY
ONE POSITIONS TO INCREASE THE
CAPACITY FOR OUR DISASTER
LOGISTICS AND PLANNING BRANCH.
CHANGE COORDINATES AND EXECUTES
LOGISTICS AND MAJOR INCIDENTS
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS SUCH
AS BUILDING AND SUPPORTING
OPERATIONAL STAGING AREAS AND
BASE CAMPS AND MANAGING AND
COORDINATING AND FACILITATING
THE DELIVERY OF. E. P. ACROSS
THE STATE. N. OR ESTABLISHING
VACCINATION OR TESTING SITES
WHAT MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
THESE FOLKS HAVE DONE NOW
SEVERAL TIMES OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS B. DISASTER
LOGISTICS SECTION. HAS BEEN A
CRITICAL RESOURCE CAPABILITY AT
ALL HAS ADVANCED FROM WILDFIRES
EARTHQUAKES THE POP THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EVENTS HELLO YES IS
INCREASING INCREDIBLY BUSY BUT
THIS ABSOLUTE JUST SIX UNIT HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE BUSIEST AREAS
THAT WE'VE SEEN. IN THE AGENCY
SO WHAT WITH THAT- MANAGER ALL.
STOP AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DIRECTOR WE
MOVE ON TO FIND FOR YOUR
COMMENTS PLEASE. THE AFTERNOON
STEVEN BANKS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I NOTHING ADDITIONAL
TO ADD TO THE PRESENTATION THAT
CAL YES MAN BUT AVAILABLE TO
HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS AS NEEDED
. OKAY THANK YOU- AND THE LA O'S
OFFICE PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DREW SUPPORT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE BEFORE I
PROVIDE OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THE GOVERNOR SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
THAT WERE PRESENTED TODAY I WANT
TO PROVIDE OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
AND APPLIED MORE BROADLY TO THE-
YES BUDGET SPECIFICALLY WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTLY ADMINISTRATION TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
ENHANCING THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CAPACITY. AND REQUIRE A
REVIEW OF THE- YES BASE BUDGET
IN LIGHT PLAN WE FIND THIS TO BE
NECESSARY FOR SEVERAL DIFFERENT
REASONS TO BEGIN WITH THE NUMBER
AND SEVERITY OF EMERGENCY USE
HAS INCREASED IN RECENT YEARS
AND- IN ADDITION TO THIS THERE'S
VARIOUS REASONS SUCH AS CLIMATE
CHANGE TO THINK THAT THIS
INCREASED LEVEL OF EMERGENCIES
WILL PROCESS AND IN THE FUTURE.
IN RESPONSE AS SHOWN IN THE
CHART ON PAGE THIRTY THREE THE
GENDER OF THE STATE HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY AUGMENTED THE
ARIANESPACE BUDGET FROM TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND 201-718-2400
AND FIFTY FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO APPROVE ALL
OF THE GOVERNORS OPERATIONS.
GREASE FIRE DIVISIONAL FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OR 9%
INCREASE ON WHAT WE FIND THAT
IT'S REASONABLE FOR THE GOVERNOR
TO PROPOSE TO INCREASE THE
STATE'S RESPONSE CAPACITY
FURTHER IT'S DIFFICULT AT THIS
TIME TO ASSESS WHETHER THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS BEING
PRESENTED TODAY REFLECT THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE APPROACH
FOR DOING SO BECAUSE THE
PROPOSALS DON'T APPEAR TO BE
TIED TO SPECIFIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSABLES AND JACKETS. IN
VIEW OF THIS WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR ENHANCING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY BY
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THIS PLAN SHOULD INCLUDE. GOALS
FOR THE LEVEL OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CAPACITY THE STATE
NEEDS TO MAINTAIN AND CLEAR
OBJECTIVES FOR MEETING THESE
GOALS ASSESSMENT OF EXISTING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY.
IDENTIFICATIONS OF GAPS OR
WEAKNESSES IN CURRENT RESPONSE
CAPACITY THAT PREVENT THE STATE
FROM MEETING ITS EMERGENCY
RESPONSABLES AND ASSESSMENT OF
THE LEVEL OF STAFFING NECESSARY
TO SUPPORT BASE WORKLOAD AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY
GOALS. AND A PLAN FOR OBTAINING. THE NEEDED STAFFING. WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THE- YES BASED BUDGET BE
REVIEWED. IN THE LIGHT OF THE
STRATEGIC PLAN TO DETERMINE
WHETHER IT'S EXISTING RESOURCES
ARE MEETING THE STATE'S
STRATEGIC PLAN GOALS WHETHER
THERE ARE SOME RESOURCES THAT
COULD BE REALLOCATED TO HIGHER
PRIORITY USES. AND THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THE REASON AUGMENTATIONS
PROVIDED SO YES I'VE ALREADY
PROVIDED THE NECESSARY RESOURCES
TO ACHIEVE THE STATE'S GOALS.
BOMB WE WOULD KNOW BUT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REQUEST THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JURY OUT
THIS REVIEW AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS A UNIT DEDICATED TO
THIS TYPE OF WORK. IN TERMS OF
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS THAT WERE
PRESENTED ARE WE DO HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON EACH OF THEM.
FIRST WE RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
FUNDING RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR CHAPTER
SEVENTY SEVEN FORTY FOUR OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT'S EIGHTY
FIFTY EIGHT. PART FIVE EIGHTY
EXCUSE ME. WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE REVIEW OF JOHNNY
WORKING . PLANS FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. OBVIOUSLY THE WORK
WILL BE STATUTORILY REQUIRED AND
IN ADDITION THE REVIEW- THE
COUNTY EMERGENCY PLANS FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS CAN HELP
INFORM OH YES OF WHAT LOCAL
CAPACITIES ARE TO ASSIST THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHICH COULD IN TURN
INFORM THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT WE-
RECOMMEND. IN ADDITION- WE FIND
THAT THE REMAINING THREE
PROPOSALS TO SUPPORT CAPACITY
PROPOSAL THE REGIONAL RESPONSE
PROPOSAL AND A LOGISTICS
MANAGEMENT PROPOSAL ARE
DIFFICULT TO ASSESS AN ABSENCE
OF A STRATEGIC PLAN. ON THE
BASELINE BUDGET REVIEW FOR
EXAMPLE THE SUPPORT CAPACITY
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL STAFFING FOR
MULTIPLE- YES SOME GYMS I'VE
RECEIVED AUGMENTATIONS IN RECENT
YEARS WITHOUT A STRATEGIC PLAN
ANYBODY'S BUDGET REVIEW IT'S
UNCLEAR WHY THE RESOURCES
PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED WERE
INSUFFICIENT WHAT THE TOTAL
LEVEL- YES RESOURCE NEED IS.
ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING THESE GROUP BUT DURING
SO ON A YEAR TERM BASIS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE RESOURCES WHILE
THE STRATEGIC PLAN AND- BASED
BUDGET REVIEW WERE BEING
COMPLETED AND THEN ONCE THEY'RE
COMPLETED. THEIR PROPOSALS COULD
BE REASSESSED WITH THE BENEFIT
INFORMATION FROM THOSE OVER
ARCHING ASSESSMENTS I'M NOT
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THE SITE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
HELLO SENATOR KERRY ROOM BUT IF
I NO- YES I'D LIKE TO ASK IF-
DIRECTOR GHILARDUCCI IF YOU
COULD RESPOND TO THE L. A. O.'S-
COMMENTS- I DO THINK THAT THERE
IS AN ISSUE OF- HOW DO WE ENGAGE
OUR HOW DO YOU ENGAGE IN
STRATEGIC PLANNING- AND COME UP
WITH IS A WAY TO ADDRESS THE
STAFFING LEVELS BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE AS AS YOU WERE SOMEONE SAID
THIS IS INCREASED EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS IT'S THE NEW
NORMAL SO. HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF ELIO.
THANKS MADAM CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND- WELL FIRST OF ALL-
BRIDGET B. LA- RECOMMENDING THAT
YOU APPROVE FUNDING FOR THESE
REQUESTS- OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD ALTHOUGH- I THINK THAT-
AND I APPRECIATE THE LA- A
KNOWLEDGE OF THE CHALLENGES
FACING THE ORGANIZATION. AND THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
OUR I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT- YES IT IS I
GUESS THE WEIGHT THE BEST
DESCRIBE IT. IS MUCH LIKE A CITY
GOVERNMENT IT'S A UNIQUE
ORGANIZATION STATE GOVERNMENT-
WE ARE A WE HAVE A JOB AND AN
EXECUTIVE DEPARTMENT OUR CITY
MANAGEMENT. WE'VE GOT OUR FIRE
AND RESCUE DEPARTMENT THAT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENT WE HAVE
OUR HIGHLY PUBLIC WORKS
DEPARTMENTS ARE PLANNING AND-
PLANNING DIVISION DEPARTMENT ALL
OF THESE ARE. OUR FUNCTIONS-
THAT- HAVE THEIR OWN VERTICALS
NOW THE CROSSOVER COORDINATE
WITH EACH OTHER- TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY DELIVER THE PROGRAMS
BY WHICH WE NEED TO IN SUPPORT
OF OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA DURING.
WHETHER WE'RE IN PLANNING OR
PREPARED THIS PHASE OR WERE
ACTUALLY RESPONDING ALL THE WAY
THROUGH RECOVERY WHEN WE SEE
THESE DEVASTATING. DISASTERS
THAT LITERALLY IN MANY CASES NOW
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE
LITERALLY WIPED OUT ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES HI AND IT TAKES A
VICTORY TAKES UP THE WHOLE CITY
IN THIS CASE TAKES ON A WHOLE-
YES- ED TO COME TOGETHER TO BE
ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY. RESPOND AND
RECOVER TO THESE EVENTS SO IN
PREVIOUS YEARS WHEN WE HAVE
ASKED FOR RESOURCES WE HAVE
BUILT THOSE RESOURCE REQUEST
AROUND THE NEEDS. AT THE TIME AS
THE EMERGENCIES THAT WE WERE
DEALING WITH AND THEY WERE.
FOCUSED IN THESE VERTICALS THAT
EXIST WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT- AS
B. DISASTERS AND EMERGENCIES
INCREASING COMPLEXITY AND SPEED
AND SCALE AND SCOPE. WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS NOW ASKING AND
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL
IN THE AREAS THAT- HOW DIFFERENT
ROLES OR RESPONSIBILITIES BUT
ARE STILL NONETHELESS UNDER- YES
I GUESS THAT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT. WE ARE NOT SORT OF ONE
SIZE FITS ALL HERE IT'S A VERY-
DIFFERENT. PEOPLE FOR DIFFERENT
KINDS OF I ACTIONS THE AND THIS
PIZZATHIS IS THAT- GENERAL IT'S
HARD TO. HIRE PEOPLE IN THE
NORMAL. ENVIRONMENT THAT WE FACE
IN CALIFORNIA EVEN IN THE
COUNTRY NOW PEOPLE COMING TO
WORK- IN THIS FIELD- THIS WORK
IS NOT FOR EVERYONE. IT'S
EXTREMELY DEMANDING. IT'S TOUGH
WORK. IT IS SO EMOTIONALLY.
DIFFICULT FROM WHAT WE SEE WHAT
WE SMELL WHAT WE ENCOUNTER
FAMILY LOST DEATH CHECK TRUCK
AND SO IT TAKES A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF EFFORT TO GET THE
RIGHT PEOPLE INTO THESE JOBS.
AND WHEN WE- BUT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING TO STEP
UP DON'T GET ME WRONG WE DO HAVE
DEDICATED FOLKS THAT WANT TO
STEP UP BUT WHEN WE TELL
CANDIDATES AT THE EMPLOYMENT. IS
ONLY UP UP FOR THREE YEARS ARE
NOT PERMITTED IT TENDS TO BE A
DEAL BREAKER AND WE CAN NEVER
SEEM TO CATCH UP- AND- AND OF
COURSE WE CAN NEVER INSURE FOR-
OPERATIONAL CONTINUITY AND
EXPERTISE TO BE DEVELOPED
BECAUSE- OR OR CONSTANTLY IN
THIS CYCLE AS WE GET CLOSE TO
THAT. TWO OR THREE YEAR PERIOD
MOST PEOPLE ARE AROUND YOU KNOW
BOUNCING OUT. OR LEAVING OR IF
WE EVEN GET THEM TO STAY SO I'M
NOT OPPOSED TO WORKING WITH THE
LA- AND THE LEGISLATURE IN
BUILDING OUT A STAFFING PLAN
COULD PICK AN ARTICULATE THIS.
BETTER BUT I WILL BUT I WILL I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
I'M SAYING TODAY THAT- I THINK
THE WAY IT'S BEEN- DERISIVE IT'S
A LITTLE MISS. BY CONFUSING AND-
IN REALLY- WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR. IS A DIRECT- DIRECT ME
BASED UPON WHAT THE- CONDITIONS
TODAY AND WHAT WE PROJECT INTO
THE FUTURE. ALL WILL BE HANDED
OUT WE ARE ALREADY AT A
DISADVANTAGE WE HAVE A- STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER THAT HAS BEEN
. FULLY TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
ACTIVATED FOR OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
DAYS AND- AND WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH- WELL SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. TO NOW WE HAVE ADDED
FIFTY THOUSAND THAT'S FIVE ZERO
THOUSAND HOMES DESTROYED IN
CALIFORNIA- FOR WILDFIRE ALONE.
NOT TO MENTION EARTHQUAKES AND-
FLOODING IN OTHER KINDS OF
EVENTS WE HAD AND ALL OF THAT IS
TAKEN A LOT OF THAT EFFORT TO
GET THESE THESE COMMUNITIES
RECOVERED- AND- AND BACK UP ON
THEIR FEET. SO WITHOUT ALL ALL
STOP TO SAY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
ELIO OPRY SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE THIS WITH YOU AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU DIRECTOR DEALER D.
G. R. I APPRECIATE- YOU'RE
REMINDING US. ABOUT ALL THE-
EXTRAORDINARY WORK OF YOURS
STATEWIDE TEAM YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND EVERYONE WHO PUTS IN WELL
WHEN WE'RE IN TIME OF NEED SO-
FROM THAT AND YOU CAN COUNT ON
US TO BE AS SUPPORTIVE AS AS
POSSIBLE- IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY THE LEGISLATURE
TO LOOK AT. THE MOST EFFICIENT-
AT THE SAME TIME THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF YOU WE NEED TO
LOOK AT. YOU KNOW THE EFFICIENCY
AND- AND THE PLANNING BECAUSE WE
TOO DON'T CANNOT SAY ANYTHING
FOR SURE- FOR AS LONG AS WE'D
LIKE TO- BUT- THAT'S DEFINITELY
WITHIN OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES SO- WHEN
COURAGE YOU ABSOLUTELY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO- COME UP WITH A MORE
STRATEGIC PLANNING. PROCESS ON
THE ON THE STAFFING- ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WANT TO MAKE A-
COMMENTER QUESTION NOPE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
FOR PRESENTING. AND WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ALSO- OH YES- ISSUE.
EIGHT WHICH IS HEADQUARTERS OFF
MODERNIZATION. YOU'RE ON AGAIN
DIRECTOR. OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR PRECIADO IT- SO IN IN
PRIOR YEARS- THE LEGISLATURE I
HAD APPROVED SEVERAL CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO CALORIE ASKED AT
THE STATE HEADQUARTERS HERE ARE
LOCATED IN MAJOR. CALIFORNIA
RIGHT OUTSIDE OF SACRAMENTO- THE
PROJECTS INCLUDED THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTRE ALL ITS
SECURITY IMPROVEMENTS- WORK BOTH
WITHIN THE BUILDING AND AL AND
OUTSIDE OF THE BUILDING- AND SO
THIS BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
FIND THE NEXT. PHASE OF EACH OF
THESE EXISTING PROJECTS- AND
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES
SUPPORT COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
EACH- INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
SECURITY GUARDS THAT WOULD COME
WITH THAT THEY NEED TO APPLE PIE
THIS IS THE SECURITY OF A BRIDGE
HERE. LEASING LEASE FUNDING FOR
TEMPORARY SWING SPACE FOR STAFF
WHILE THE- STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER IS BEING MODIFIED SO THAT
ORIGINAL PROJECT THAT WAS
FUNDED- AND THE STUDY FOR THE
RIGHT FOR THE- THE PLANS AT ALL.
AND NOW WE WILL BE MOVING INTO
THAT- CONSTRUCTION PHASE WHICH
MEANS THAT WE OUGHT TO WE
LITERALLY HAVE TO TAKE THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER WHICH AS YOU
AS YOU KNOW WHAT I JUST
MENTIONED. IT'S A VERY VERY
CRITICAL PLACE AND AM VERY BUSY
PLACE AND RECREATE IT IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE FOR THE PERIOD
OF TIME WHILE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DOING THE CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION ABOUT. THE STATE
OPERATION SHATTUCK SHELTER-
AFTER THIS. FOR ISSUE EIGHT AND
AGAIN HAPPY. ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR AND THE- WE HAVE A
OF LOT OF WHAT IT'S LIKE TO MOVE
OUT OF A BUILDING AND- INTO
SWING SPACE. WE HEAR IT RING
RECREATE WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING THEM IN THE CAPITAL SO
WE GOT A LITTLE TASTEOF THAT-
CAN WE HAVE A- LET'S SEE IF
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. A PARTICULAR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I HAVE
NOTHING DOWN BUT I'M AVAILABLE
FOR- QUESTIONS IF NEEDED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- ELLIE OLDS
OFFICE PLEASE- WE DID NOT RAISE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THESE
PROPOSALS GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVEON TO
THE ISSUE NINE BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NINE CAN WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. DR BRICK BUILDING.
SENATOR DORADO HERE THAT ARE
GROWTH SENATOR CORTEZ SENIOR
SENATOR NEWMAN HERE THANK YOU
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY OKAY WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NINE- WHICH IS IMPLEMENTING A
NINE EIGHT EIGHT BEHAVIORAL
MENTAL HEALTH HOTLINE- DIRECTOR
GHILARDUCCI. THANKS I'M SURE-
OKAY ON THIS ONE UP THE BUDGET
IS PROPOSING SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND TO
IMPLEMENT A NEW FEDERALLY
MANDATED NINETY EIGHT EIGHT
SUICIDE HOTLINE CALL SYSTEM TO
INCREASE THE EASY ACCESSIBILITY
TO PROVIDE HELP FOR THOSE
CONSIDERING SUICIDE. OR SELF
HARM- THE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION MANDATED DID
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CARRIERS TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT SYSTEM BY JULY SIXTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO. A
CALORIE S. AS THE OPERATOR OF
THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IS PROVIDING THE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT CAPABILITY AND
EXPERTISE TO SET UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THESE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT CALLS THOSE WHO DIAL
NINE EIGHT EIGHT WILL BE
DIRECTED TO ONE OF THE EXISTING
THIRTEEN A LIFELINE CALL CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE. THE CENTERS
ALREADY PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE WITH MENTAL HEALTH-
SORRY MENTAL DISTRESS AND THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL ENSURE
FOR APPROPRIATE TECHNICAL
ENHANCEMENTS TO- TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE NEEDING SERVICES RECEIVED
HELP OR FICTIONALLY. AS WELL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
FUNDS TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM- THOSE FUNDS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN COMMITTED. IN THE
HHS PROGRAM AREA SO FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE NOT AVAILABLE
UNFORTUNATELY FOR CALLOW YESS
TECHNICAL SUPPORT OF THE
PROGRAM- WE WILL CONTINUE TO
COORDINATE WITH HHS AGENCY AS WE
IMPLEMENTED- THE TECHNICAL PIECE
OF THIS AS THEY IMPLEMENT- THE
PROGRAMMATIC PIECE- SO AGAIN
THAT'S UP THAT'S WHAT THIS
PROGRAM IS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE A TEAM
HERE WITH. OUR SPECIALIST IF YOU
HAVE ANY PARTICULAR. ITEMS YOU
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THIS.
THANK YOU BUT THE PART OF FINE.
JURISTE OR SEND. IN ORDER TO
FINANCE IT NOT NO REAL
ADDITIONAL PRESENTATION JUST
REITERATE THE DIRECTOR SAYING
THAT YOU KNOW WE THE MINISTRY
FOR MAINE'S COMMITTED TO
MAXIMIZING USE OF FEDERAL FUNDS
WERE POSSIBLE SO TO THE EXTENT
YOU KNOW WITHIN A FIGHTER
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
COULD BE USED FOR THIS PURPOSE
WE WOULD CERTAINLY LOOK INTO
THAT. WE COORDINATE REGULARLY
WITH OUR AGENT JUST COUNTERPARTS
TO TRYING TO FIND OUT BUT AT THE
MOMENT- WE'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY
THAT'S AVAILABLE SO THAT'S WHY
THE PROPOSALS GENERAL FUND.
BEFORE YOU. WITHOUT AVAILABLE
THEY'LL HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. TANK YOU AN L. A-
PLEASE. SO WE DON'T HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL IN
PRINCIPLE GIVEN THAT IT'S
REQUIRED- IMPLEMENTATION BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOWEVER IT
WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE
WERE POTENTIAL FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WERE NOT ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE PROPOSAL AND SO WE WERE
WITHHOLDING RECOMMENDATION AND
SO- WE WERE ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION ON WHETHER SUCH
FARMS WERE BEING AVAILABLE AND
SO WE WILL WORK WITH. US AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE OR IF ALL AAILABLE
FUNDING HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
THE- HHS- AGENCY AND THEN WE
WILL- UPDATE THE COMMITTEE AT
THAT TIME. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I THINK I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- WHAT IS THE
TIMELINE OF IMPLEMENTATION SINCE
THE FEDERAL MANDATE TAKES EFFECT
IN JULY. A MAN CHAIRMAN I HAVE
OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR MITCH
MEDICARE WHICH OVERSEES THE
PROGRAM I- YES GIVE YOU THE
SPECIFICS ON THIS OKAY I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I THINK WE HAVE
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO WERE
WERE ABLE TO DO RIGHT NOW IS
WE'RE REDIRECTING SOME
RESOURCING RIGHT NOW TO. START
THE ASSESSMENT PROCESS ALL WHILE
WE'RE WORKING WITH- THESE
THIRTEEN CENTERS AND BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF. LOOKING AT THE
CONTRACT THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
AND TO DO THE EVALUATION OF THE
OF THE OF THE EQUIPMENT
NECESSARY AND THE MODIFICATIONS
NECESSARY TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO START
WORKING. THE CONTRACTS IF
FUNDING BECOMES AVAILABLE THAT
WE CAN START THE IMPLEMENTATION
TO TRY TO DO THAT- PROCUREMENT
AND DO THAT AS RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE- WE'RE ALSO DOING THE
COORDINATION WITH AND I WANT TO
BUY THREE BOARD ITS LONG RANGE
PLANNING LONG RANGE PLANNING
COMMITTEE. AND THAT IN TURN
MEANS WITH ALL THE LOCAL
SHERIFF'S FIRE CHIEFS AND POLICE
CHIEFS. AS THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
PROGRESS SO THAT'S KIND OF THE
ACTIVITIES ARE WORKING NOW- IN
STARTING IN SOME AREAS AND
WORKING MORE AGGRESSIVE THAN
OTHERS. IF WE RECEIVE THE
FUNDING HERE IT WILL TAKE
APPROXIMATELY TWO YEARS BUT WHAT
THIRTEEN EXISTING SITES THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
CURRENTLY TAKE CALLS FOR- YOU
KNOW- MENTAL HEALTH OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES- REMAIN
OPEN AND THE TRAFFIC FOR OVER
TWO NINE EIGHT- THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
THOSE CALLS- ONCE THAT HAPPENS.
WHY WHAT- YES NEED TO DO WHAT WE
IS WHY IT IS FUNNY AS **** AS-
THE ABILITY TO MOVE A CALL BACK
FORTH. BETWEEN A NINE ONE ONE
CALL THAT SHOULD BE AND I MADE A
CALL AND I MADE A CALL THAT
SHOULD BE A NINE ONE ONE CALL.
AND TO ENSURE THAT THE LOCATION
OF WHERE YOU'RE CALLING FROM. A
PHONE NUMBER THAT YOU'RE CALLING
FROM. IS THAT YOU STAY IN THE
QUEUE IS A PRIORITY AND NOT
GOING INTO THE BACK OF THE
QUEUE- SOMEWHERE WHILE YOU'RE
WAITING- IT HAPPENS SEAMLESSLY.
AND THAT INTERACTION AND THAT
MOVEMENTS ARE TO THE LOCAL LEVEL
BUT TAKES PLACE IN SO THE
INTEGRATION THAT TECHNICAL
SOLUTION. IS WHAT- YES IT'S
GOING TO WORK ON AND THAT
INCLUDES TEXTING- TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL HAPPENS- PROPERLY WITH
THE NEXT GENERATION ON ONE
PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE ALREADY
WORKING ON AS WELL SO. HOPEFULLY
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE- WEEK SO
GREATLY APPRECIATE. THAT
SERVICE. AND IT I'M SURE IT'S
JUST. A DIFFERENT KIND OF LIFE
AND DEATH. SITUATION ARE THESE
THE ONLY RESOURCES FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION. IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. OR DO YOU DO EXPECT THAT
THEY'LL BE- ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
NEEDS. I'M SURE THIS IS A SMOG
AND CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR HERE
AND- YES- PERHAPS ARE I THINK
THESE ARE THE ONLY RESOURCES
THAT OUR AGENCY WILL BE
REQUESTING AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAY HAVE MORE VISIBILITY
ON KIND OF WHAT OUR COLLEAGUES
IN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. SIDE OF THE HOUSE MAY
BE REQUESTING RELATIVE TO
PROGRAMMING AND THE RESPONSE
ASPECT OF IT. I'M SURE STEVEN
BENEFITS PARTNER FINANCE I I'M
NOT CURRENTLY TRACKING ANY
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AT THIS
TIME- I HAVE A LOT HAPPY TO.
COORDINATE WITH MY TEACHERS
COUNTERPARTS AND- FOLLOW UP ON
THAT BUT I'M I'M NOT TRACKING
ANYTHING ELSE THE MOMENT. OKAY
IF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS
. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
HEARING NONE AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FOR THIS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE- WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE TEN. THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE EARTHQUAKE
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM. DIRECTOR
RIGHT EXPAND SHARE- BOY HERE'S
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM-
AND- AND THIS IS- OUR PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR A
LITTLE WHILE NOW- AND NOW WE'RE
REQUESTING AN AGENDA ITEM OF
SEVENTEEN POINT ONE MILLION AND
THREE POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THIS-
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
PROGRAM- AS YOU MAY KNOW THIS IS
A STATE OF THE ART SEISMIC
WARNING SYSTEM DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE EARLY WARNING OF AN
IMPENDING EARTHQUAKE OUR SYSTEM
IS STATEWIDE AND HAS ALREADY
BEEN A CENTRAL AND SUCCESSFUL IN
PROVIDING EARLY NOTIFICATIONS OF
EARTHQUAKES ON A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS. APPROVAL OF THIS
REQUEST WOULD DO A FEW THINGS
NECESSARY FOR CONTINUED
OPERATION OF THE SYSTEM FIRST IT
WOULD INCREASE THE EARTHQUAKE
SENSOR DENSITY INTO THE RURAL
PARTS OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA A
PART OF THE EFFORT IS TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH COVERAGE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- SO THAT WE
GET THE MOST IT REACHED- DATA UP
FROM WHAT WAS ON THE SENSORS A
SECOND ITEM WOULD BE TO FIND
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY. BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO EDUCATE
SOCIALLY ISOLATED GROUPS IN
UNDER SERVED COMMUNITIES ON THE
PROGRAM AND HOW TO UTILIZE IT-
TO SAVE LIVES AND PROPERTY-
WITHIN YOUR AREA- THERE'S
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
APPLICATION YOU DOWNLOAD THE APP
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT- THE
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING ON YOUR
PHONE- BUT THERE'S OTHER WAYS TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE END FOR. AND
EDUC IS A PART THAT MATTER USE
IT. AND THEN THE THIRD IS- THAT
WOULD WOULD BE TO SUPPORT. THE
NECESSARY RESEARCH ON ON NEW
PUBLIC ALERT METHOD SO PART OF
THIS IS ALWAYS- STAYING ON
CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PUSHING OUT
THE- SIGNAL- AND THE ALERT. TO
INDIVIDUALS AND TO- TO THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY- TO THE
VARIOUS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
SECTORS LIKE RETAIL- AND HEALTH
AND OUR PORCH- TO BE ABLE TO-
YOU KNOW IN THE CASE OF. OF RAIL
A SLOWING OR STOPPING A TRAIN
PRIOR TO THE SHAKING REACHING-
THE TRAIN TRACKS AND DERAILING A
TRAIN FOR EXAMPLE SO WORK THIS
IS THIS CONSTANT OUR RESEARCH
EFFORT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE ON
THE CUTTING EDGE. WILL BE
IMPORTANT SO THIS OUT PROPOSAL
IS- A PROPOSAL TO- CONTINUE TO-
TO AMPLIFY THE THIS THE. SYSTEM
AND PUT IT IN PLACE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. I THINK IT IS NOT BAD BY WAY
OF PRESENTATION BUT AVAILABLE TO
HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU-
AND LA- PLEASE. SIMILAR TO THE
PROPOSALS- WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT THIS
APPROACH PROPOSAL BE APPROVED ON
A THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS
AND BE RECONSIDERED AFTER THE
COMPLETION OF THE STRATEGIC
PLANNER BASELINE BUDGET REVIEW I
MENTIONED EARLIER- WELL THE
SYSTEM IS POTENTIALLY PROMISING
WITHOUT A STRATEGIC PLAN IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE CURRENT
APPROACH TO BUILDING OUT THE
SYSTEM ALIGNS WITH THE STATE'S
OVERALL RESPONSE CAPACITY GOALS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER THE CURRENT EFFORTS TO
EXPAND THE SYSTEM WOULD PROVIDE
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY BENEFITS OR
WHETHER ALTERNATIVE STRATEGIES
SUCH AS INCREASED FUNDING FOR
BUILDING SEISMIC RETROFITS WOULD
BETTER INDICATE. THE POTENTIAL
HARM FROM EARTHQUAKES. TIONS
OKAY. GOOD QUESTIONS- DIRECTOR
DEALER DID YOU COULD YOU RESPOND
TO THOSE COMMENTS AND CONCERNS.
I KNOW THEY'RE SIMILAR TO US
ANOTHER ISSUE BUT- THANKS
MANAGER- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I
THINK IT DID THE ISSUE IS
SATIATED WITH THE- STRATEGIC
PLAN ON. PERSONNEL AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE LA I WAS
SPEAKING ABOUT BEFORE. WARNING
PROGRAM IS OUT OF LEGISLATIVELY-
IT YOU KNOW MANDATED PROGRAM
THAT- THAT HAS BEEN IN PLACE NOW
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND- HAS HAD
YOU KNOW STRATEGIC PLANS AND
OPERATIONAL PLANS AROUND THAT
SPIN BRIEFINGS TO THE
LEGISLATURE THERE'S AN ADVISORY
BOARD THAT HAS LEGISLATED
PARTNERSHIP ON IT. SO YOU KNOW
HOW CAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LA- TO CLARIFY- WE KNOW WHAT THE
NEEDSARE THERE- AND THEN
SPECIFICALLY ON THE ISSUE OF
THE- ON THE ISSUE OF THE OF THE
PERSONNEL REQUIREMENTS IN THAT
PROGRAM- AGAIN YOU KNOW MY
COMMENTS FROM BEFORE BUT HOW
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE LA- TO.
TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH THIS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT WILL BE
A- COLLEAGUE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NOT. ENOUGH DURING A
JOB. OKAY RIGHT- I DO HAVE. ONE
FINAL QUESTION ON THE ISSUE OF
THE CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC MEDIA
MEDIA'S ROLE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
TELEVISION'S ROLE- IN THE EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM- ARE. ASKING FOR
A BOAT. PILOT EXPANSION- AND I'D
HOPE THAT YOU WILL. SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER THAT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- WE ARE CONSIDERING IT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING WITH ABOUT-
BROADCASTERS AND THAT CALIFORNIA
. ELEVATION AND RADIO FOLKS-
WHEN I SPEAK SPOKE EARLIER TO.
RESEARCH ON NEW WAYS OF DOING
THE PUBLIC A WORK ALERTS JUST
METHODS THIS IS ONE AREA THAT I
WAS TALKING ABOUT AND SO- YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR THAT THAT BAD THOUGH IT'S
SPEED AT WHICH WE CAN GET THE
SIGNAL OUT BECAUSE AS YOU. AS
YOU KNOW IT REALLY IS A MATTER
OF SECONDS THAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE HERE AND- THE FASTER
WE CAN GET THE SIGNAL OUT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE MORE- THE
MARKET COULD HAPPEN MORE LIVES
CAN BE SAVED SO- CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO. CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
BUT- WE WOULD LIKE TO GAUGE THEM
EVEN FURTHER- WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR I MEAN THAT. IS A DUMB.
IN A SOMETIMES THE THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY AS GREAT AS IT IS AND
FAST IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES CAN.
REALLY GET ALL CLOGGED UP THE
MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE USING IT SO
I WORRY ABOUT BEING TOO
DEPENDENT ON. CELL PHONES. YOU
KNOW TO GET THE WORD OUT ON A ON
A LARGER SCALE- APPRECIATE THAT-
OKAY- MOVING ON TO ISSUE ELEVEN
WE'RE ALMOST DONE HERE. ISSUE
ELEVEN WHICH IS FIRE AND RESCUE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM OF AGAIN
DIRECTOR. GHILARDUCCI OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THEN THANKS
TO MOVE SOME BOXES OF RAPIDLY
IT'S GREAT- SO THIS THIS- AGAIN
ONE OF THE VERTICALS AND AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT WE ASK IS
ARE OUR FIRE AND RESCUE
DIVISION- AND AS I KNOW YOU KNOW
WE- WILL HAVE MANY FIRES IN YOU
AND YOUR DISTRICT WE- WE HAVE AS
A PART OF THAT. FIRE AND RESCUE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM I'M A VERY
ROBUST- IF PROGRAM WHERE WE
HAVE- YES FIRE ENGINES AND
EQUIPMENT THAT WE ASSIGNED TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN A
PARTNERSHIP- WHEN THERE IS A
MAJOR FIRE MAJOR DISASTER
THEY'RE READY ALL HAZARDS- COULD
BE FOR EARTHQUAKE FIRE FLOOD OR-
OR TERRORIST ATTACK WHATEVER WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MOVE THESE.
THESE ARE PIECES OF EQUIPMENT-
THEY AUGMENT THE STATE'S FORCES
THERE FORCE MULTIPLIER- AND
THEY'RE SUPPORTED WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
SO THIS PROPOSAL- PROPOSES
ELEVEN POINT TWO MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND ELEVEN POSITIONS TO
MAINTAIN- THE STATE FIRE RESCUE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM FIRE FLEET SO-
AND I'VE GOT CHIEF. CHIEF
UPRIGHT MARSHALL HERE'S THE
STATE'S FIRE RESCUE CHIEF- BUT
TALK MORE IN DETAIL ABOUT IT
SHOULD BE QUESTIONS BUT BUT YOU
KNOW HELLO HELLO YES PROVIDES.
THIS THESE RESOURCES AND THEY
NEED TO BE- MAINTAINED GIVEN THE
READ THE NUMBER ON- AND THE AND
THE AND THE FREQUENCY OF USE
THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING- WITH
THIS A QUICK MET- AND- AND SO
THAT'S PART OF THIS PROPOSAL IS
TO. PROVIDE US SUPPORT CAPACITY
FOR ALL OF THAT A QUICK MINUTE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S A
REPLACEMENT CYCLE- BUT MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE MAINTAINED
APPROPRIATELY AND THAT WE CAN
COUNT ON THEM WHEN THEY MEET ARE
NEEDED. AND THE SECOND PART OF
THIS. PROPOSAL- IS FOUR MILLION
ALL ORDERS AT APRIL RESERVATION
TO ENHANCE OUR THIS. FIRE AND
RESCUE. MUTUAL AID TO BY
TRANSFERRING OUR TRAINING
OPERATIONS CENTER FROM. WHAT WAS
ONCE A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
RESCUE TRAINING AUTHORITY TO
CALIFORNIA SPECIALIZED TRAINING
INSTITUTE WHICH IS THE TRADING
ARM. OF UP- WE ASK- BECAUSE BY
UTILIZING THE CALVARY
SPECIALIZED TRAINING IS TO
PROVIDE FIREFIGHTER TRAINING
INCLUDING SPECIALIZED AND HIGHLY
TECHNICAL RESCUE TRAINING- THE
SYSTEM WILL BE BETTER POSITIONED
TO RESPOND TO DISASTERS. BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- THIS IS
REALLY SOMETHING BAD IS- ALL
FIRE AGENCIES IN THE STATE. ARE
PARTICIPATING IN IN AND CAN
BENEFIT FROM. IT ALIGNS WITH OUR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS
THAT ALIGNS WITH OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROGRAMS AND IT BRINGS
OUT THIS FIRE- TRAINING PIECE
PARTICULARLY THE TECHNICAL
RESCUE PEACE. ARE IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THAT SO THAT WE ARE
APPROACHING THINGS- AS I SAY IN
A ONE TO ONE FIGHT EFFORTS THIS-
THIS THIS- UNIFIED EFFORT FOR-
ENSURING THAT WE'VE GOT
CAPACITY. TO DEAL WITH ALL
HAZARDS IN THE STATE AND I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSING.
RECENTLY ON MAJOR WILDFIRES- BUT
I WILL TELL YOU THE ONE THING
THAT KEEPS ME UP AT NIGHT. HI IF
ANYTHING DOES IT'S- A BIG
EARTHQUAKE IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
AND I KNOW IN YOUR DISTRICT I'M
SURE THIS IS A- FACTOR OF
CONCERN- BUT- WE HAVEN'T HAD IT
REALLY YES IS THE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE. WELL WE HAD MODERATE
SIZE QUAKES BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE GOT
ENOUGH CAPACITY AND CAPABILITY
TO RESPOND WHEN THAT HAPPENS
WE'LL BE REALLY REALLY CRITICAL.
AND SO ALL OF THIS- ENHANCEMENT
TO THE SYSTEM. IS. DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL OF THAT IS READY
TO GO WHEN THESE EVENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DIRECTOR-
MOVE ON TO FINANCE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. THE MESSAGE PART
OF FINANCE- JUST ONE COMMENT IN
REGARDS TO ACT AND GET A LITTLE
BIT AHEAD OF MR SODERBERGH WHO
WILL BE UP NEXT WEEK AND
ENGENDER TALKS ABOUT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THIS IS ONE
WORD AGAIN THERE'S THAT
DISCUSSION ABOUT DEVELOPING A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR YOU CAN
FUTURE ENHANCEMENTS. TO VALUATE
FUTURE BUDGET PROPOSALS I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT WITH
SPECIALLY FIRE FLEET THIS IS
REALLY FUNDING TO MAINTAIN
EXISTING NUMBER OF APPARATUS. SO
ALL OF THOSE FRONT ALL OF THOSE
APPARATUS HAVE A USEFUL LIFE AND
YOU KNOW THAT THEY NEED TO BE
REPLACED ON AVERAGE BUT EVERY
FIFTEEN YEARS AND THIS FUNDING
IS REALLY ABOUT. BEING ABLE TO
REPLACE THOSE AND KEEP THEM. OUT
PROPERLY MAINTAINED SO THAT
THEY'RE AVAILABLE FOR MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM THIS ONE REALLY ISN'T
ABOUT ADDING. THAT INCREASING
NUMBER OF ENGINES OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT MAINTAINING THE FLEET
WE ALREADY HAVE. THIS WITHOUT
AVAILABLE TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- L. L. ALES
OFFICE PLEASE. YES SO WHEN THIS
PROPOSAL WAS FIRST ARE PROVIDED
TO OUR OFFICE I'M SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO THE BUYER FOR
THE PROPOSAL IT WAS UNCLEAR TO
US WHETHER OR NOT THE FUNDING-
WAS SPECIFICALLY FOR MAINTENANCE
OR WHETHER IT WAS TO ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF ENGINES
AVAILABLE. AND SO IN OUR VIEW AT
THAT TIME- WE WERE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD
ACTION INTEL- THE NATURE OF THE
PROPOSAL WAS MADE CLEAR- SO
WE'LL WORK WITH- YES AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
ABOUT WHAT PRECISELY. THE
PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO DO AND
IN TERMS OF- FIRE FLEET
CAPACITY. AND UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE AT THAT POINT. WITH
RESPECT TO THE- SEARCH AND
RESCUE- TEAMS AS WE RECOMMEND IT
SEVERAL TIMES BEFORE WE'RE ALSO
RECOMMENDING THAT THIS BE
APPROVED ON A THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS. HOWEVER WE DO KNOW
THAT PART OF THE PROPOSAL WOULD
REPLACE AN EXISTING STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP TO PROVIDE TRAINING.
WITH A STATE RUN PROGRAM AT A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER COSTS.
SPECIFICALLY UNDER THE PROPOSAL-
YES WOULD SPEND TWO MILLION MORE
ANNUALLY TO PROVIDE TRAINING
WHICH CURRENTLY COSTS THE STATE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND ANNUALLY. AND
ACCORDINGLY ABSENT ANY
JUSTIFICATION FOR INCREASING THE
COST OF TRAINING WE RECOMMEND
NOT APPROVING. THE FUNDING FOR
THAT COMPONENT OF THE SEARCH AND
RESCUE PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD ONLY
APPROVING FUNDING. FOR THE OTHER
TWO COMPONENTS SPECIFICALLY THE
LOCAL SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS
AND A MOBILE TRAINING EXERCISE
REIMBURSEMENT ON A THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM BASIS. HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU YES
OUR DIRECTOR GO DUE TO COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT IN TERMS OF. THE
INCREASED COST TO THE STATE FOR.
THE TRANSFER. OF THE OF THE
TRAINING- THERE ARE YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT IS. WHAT IS VALUE THAT
VAN. THAT'S GIVEN THAT'S CREATED
HELP. SURE LET ME- WELL IF I IF
I COULD- MANAGER JUST ON THE
ISSUE OF THE FIRE FLEET- THAT IS
NOT AN EXPANSION OF THE FIRE
FLEET- NOT TO SAY THAT. WE DON'T
NEED MORE FIRES IN THE STATE
BUT- WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR AN
EXPANSION OF A PLACE JUST TO BE
CLEAR- IT IS STRICTLY
MAINTENANCE AND ONGOING- FOR THE
EXIT. FLEET CHARTERED CLARIFY
THAT- ON THE ON THE SECOND
PIECE- BELLOWS CORRECT IT WHEN
HE SAID THAT THE ORIGINAL-
AMOUNT AS BAND- THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND FOR. TRAINING IS
WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY IN THE GPA
THAT THAT WE HAD- WERE OFFERING
TRAINING- I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
WE HAVE- TRAINING THAT IS
WOEFULLY- INEFFICIENT
INSUFFICIENT- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- TRAINING THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND WAS PUT IN THE BUDGET
YEARS AND YEARS AGO- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TRADING UP HELLO
BOB EXPERTISE OF TECHNICAL-
RESEARCHER RESCUE. CAPABILITIES
ISSUE THESE ARE THE SPECIAL
FORCES THAT IF ANYTHING EVER
FIRE SERVICE THE ABILITY TO
TRAIN THEM IN TRAINING GOOD
TRAINING AND QUALITY TRAINING
AND GETTING THIS KIND OF
EXPERTISE TRAINING- IS YOU KNOW
IT DOESN'T ISN'T CHEAP BUT IT
ALSO IS- WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
IS- PROPORTIONAL TO WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE IN
KEEPING THESE TEAMS- READY TO GO
AT THIS STAGE REQUEST FOR MUTUAL
AID RESPONSE- BUT THE LOCALS ARE
ALSO DOING A LEVEL OF TRAINING.
BUT THIS ISN'T UP ABOVE AND
BEYOND TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE
HAS THE CAPACITY TO RESPOND TO
THESE MAJOR EVENTS AND WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR- IN IN IN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY- FOR YOU KNOW-
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF ABOUT
EIGHTEEN TEAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- IS SOMETHING THAT REALLY
IS- YOU KNOW WELL YOU KNOW. IT'S
NOT IT'S JUST NOT A LOT WHEN IT
COMES TO KIND OF TRAINING AND
CAPACITY THAT'S NECESSARY SO
THAT'S OUR RESPONDED BACK BEEN A
LONG TIME SINCE WE'VE WE'VE
ADJUSTED THIS AND- AND DEAD TO
GET THESE THESE TEAMS WHERE WE
NEED THEM- WE ESTIMATE. THAT THE
COST WILL BE ABOUT THIS MUCH.
OKAY COLLEAGUES AND HE QUESTION
ARE CALM. NO THANK YOU DIRECTOR-
AND WE MOVE ON TO THE FINAL.
ISSUE I THINK YES IT IS AN ISSUE
TWELVE IS DISASTER FUNDING
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO- AGAIN A DIRECTOR
GHILARDUCCI COULD YOU RESPOND OR
PRESENT ON THIS ISSUE. SURE
BACKBENCHER US SO THE FINAL
AGENDA ITEM HERE REALLY INCLUDES
TRUE PROPOSALS ARE GOOD
ADDRESSES RESOURCES FOR THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO RESPOND TO DISASTERS
THE FIRST IS A CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT- IN THIS
CASE THIS IS A BUDGET ITEM THAT
INCLUDES A ONE TIME INCREASE. OF
A HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE HI AN ONGOING
INCREASE OF THIRTY SEVEN POINT
FOUR MILLION. TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR THE COSTS
INCURRED AS A RESULT OF
DISASTERS- IT'S BUDGET TORY
ASSOCIATE IT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT- IS
REGULARLY UPDATED IN EACH BUDGET
CYCLE AND LET ME JUST KIND OF
FRAME IS A LITTLE BIT. SO IT'S
NOT UNCOMMON GOVERNOR PROCLAIMED
A STATE OF EMERGENCY- THERE IS
AN ADVANTAGE WHETHER IT'S A
WILDFIRE EARTHQUAKE SOMETHING
THAT IS COST INFRASTRUCTURE
DAMAGE OR COST TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WEATHER. COULD BE
THEIR RESPONSE COSTS. WE MEET
NEEDS UP MORE IMPORTANT- BEAT
THE COST TO REPAIR THE DAMAGE TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT IS A IS A- PROGRAM. THAT IS
IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
75% FINE BEING ODD TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT MAY BE HAVING
COURAGE DISASTER- AND THEY
APPLY- TO THE TWO OH YES AND DO
THAT. GOVERNOR FOR- YES- THIS
SELF FIND BEING- AND IT HELPS TO
OFFSET THE COST OF THE RECOVERY.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST- ONE IN THIS
TWO PART BEES IN THE SECOND ONE-
IS MISSION TASKING
APPROPRIATION- AND THAT IS-
AUTHORIZING- HELLO YES TO-
MISSION TASK OTHER. AGENCIES ARE
TO RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES THAT
WE HAVE MISSION TASKING
AUTHORITY CURRENTLY- AND WHAT
THIS IS THAT IF I NEED TO HAVE.
A TRUE EMERGENCY AND I NEED TO
HAVE ANOTHER AGENCY RESPOND.
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD THE
CALIFORNIA CONTROL CAL FIRE
WHOMEVER- I THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTRE CAST THAT AGENCY TO
RESPOND. THERE IS NO FUN BEING
NECESSARILY IS AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT. THOSE AGENCIES TO
RESPOND THEY'RE TAKING IT OUT OF
THEIR OWN EXISTING BUDGET- WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE IN THIS IN
THIS IS BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITY FREQUENCY AND THE
CHALLENGES OF THE OF THE ON
GOING- BUT DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES MACHINE. THE AMOUNT
OF TASKINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
HAVE EXPONENTIALLY INCREASED.
WHICH HAS BEEN FAR MORE
COMPLICATED FOR AGENCY
DEPARTMENT TO THE POINT THAT WE
GOT AGENCIES APARTMENTS THAT
HAVE SORT OF. BEEN RIPPED
RETICENT ABOUT RESPONDING- UNTIL
WE CAN WORK OUT SOME FUNNY.
MECHANISM AND SO- IS OUT OF A
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD OFFER- I.
TWO MILLION. TO COVER SORT OF AN
IMMEDIATE. COST THAT WE COULD
COVER IMMEDIATE RESPONSE- FOR
AGENCIES THAT WE HAVE CAST- AND-
AND SO I'LL STOP HERE AND IT MAY
BE OFFERED FOR ME TO FIND A JOB
YOU NEED TO. BRING THESE LITTLE
BIT MORE- THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
ON BUT- AND- AND THEN ANSWER ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THESE TWO
POINTS. OKAY THANK YOU DIRECTOR
ARE WE WILL HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PLEASE. EXTREMISTS
ARE FINE IT'S JUST ONE
CLARIFICATION IS THE REQUEST IS
FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY- I THINK THE DIRECTOR
IS MUCH DIFFERENT AND THEN WE
HAD A TWENTY NINE DOLLAR ONE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO BUT TODAY JUST
TO CLARIFY ITS TEN NINE I'M
GOING IS TO REQUEST- AND JUST.
KIND OF RIFF REFERRING TO THE
AGENDA AND THE COMMENTS FROM THE
OHIO- I KNOW THERE'S SOME
DISCUSSION THERE ABOUT NINETY
EIGHT FORTY INABILITY TO USE
THAT I'M JUST COMMENTING ON THAT
BRIEFLY- NINETY FOUR HE DOES
HAVE A PROVISION AND THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE USE OF IT. AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE- BUT NINETY FORTY ALSO
HAS LIMITATIONS INTO THE AMOUNT
OF THE IN AUGMENTATION. THAT
SOME CASES CAN BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC TO SOME OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS- SMALL APARTMENTS
WITH SMALL CORPORATION AMOUNTS
AND NINETY EIGHT FORTY IS
LIMITED TO A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE
BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF
APPROPRIATION IN SOME CASES SO
YOU HAVE A YOU KNOW CORPORATION
OF BOSTON. FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
YOU'RE LIMITED TO COVER 30%
AUGMENTATION AND WHY CASES THOSE
AUGMENTATION LIMITATIONS WOULD
NOT ALLOW PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES FOR MANY OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS TO RESPOND. CASES
LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL OR POWER
CYCLE THAT MAY NEED TO GO OUT
AND DO THE REMOVAL. OF
ACTIVITIES YOU KNOW VERY QUICKLY
HERE I THOUGHT YOU SAID YOU
DIDN'T THE MOBILE EYES AND. AND
MOVE WITHIN. YOU KNOW A DAY OR
TWO- SO MAKING SURE WE HAVE MADE
TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT FUNDING
FOR THE RESPONSE ACTIVE. THAT
THEY TO DO HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE
OVER LAST FEW YEARS- OBVIOUSLY
WHEN WE HAVE A DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT. FUNDING
MECHANISM AND SO WE HAVE THAT
APPROACH BEING ABLE TO HANDLE
THAT AND THAT. SOME OF THESE
DISASTERS THAT DON'T ALWAYS
WRITES THE SAME MAGNITUDE OF A
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY
STILL REQUIRE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSES YOU KNOW THE DIRECTOR
WAS TALKING TO AND- THERE ARE
ISSUES WITH SOME OF THESE.
DEPARTMENTS THAT WE NEED- THAT
HAVE SPECIALIZED EXPERTISE TO
RESPOND TO THESE DISASTERS.
THAT'S THE NATURE OF IT AND WHY
NINETY EIGHT FOUR. CERTAINLY
THAT EXIST AND CAN BE USED FOR
RECEIVING. RESPONSE IT ALSO HAS
A BROADER. APPLICATION AND YOU
KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT WE USE
THAT OFFERING TO RESPONSE THEN
STARTS TO- IT ON THE BUILDING
USE THAT MY- FOR OTHER. COSTS
THAT YOU KNOW IT FREQUENTLY IS
USED FOR AS WELL SO. JUST
THERE'S A FEW LIMITATIONS OF
NINETY EIGHT FORTY DON'T REALLY
MEET THE- NEEDS OF THIS MISSION
TASKING- FUNDING. BUT WITHOUT
AVAILABLE TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IN THE L. A. O. COMMENTS PLEASE
. YES WE DO NOT RAISE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
INCREASE AND- CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT FUNDING.
WITH RESPECT TO THE MISSION
TASKING APPROPRIATION AS MR
BENTSEN INDICATED. WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
FOR TWO REASONS FIRST AS WAS
MENTIONED B. NINETY EIGHT FORTY
ITEMS IN THE BUDGET ALREADY
PROVIDE FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE TO BE USED FOR
UNEXPECTED OR EMERGENCY COSTS
UPON APPROVAL THE BENEFIT OF THE
NINETY EIGHT FORTY ITEMS IS THAT
THEY- ARE SUBJECT TO A GREAT
DEAL MORE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
THEN WHAT WOULD BE PROVIDED
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE ABLE
TO AUGMENT OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WITHOUT ANY LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION AND- YES WOULD ONLY
BE REQUIRED TO REPORT ONLINE-
THE AUGMENTATIONS MADE ONCE ON
MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
BOMB BLASTS. IT WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO QUITE A BIT LESS TRANSPARENCY
AND LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. WITH
REGARD TO THE LIMITATIONS ON
THAT MR MENTIONED MISTER
ROBINSON EXCUSE ME MENTIONED
ABOUT THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY
PROCESS TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED AND
ADDRESSING THOSE WE'D BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
IDENTIFY OPTIONS TO ADDRESS ANY
OF THOSE CONCERNS. HAPPY. TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I TEND TO AGREE WITH THE
LA- ON THIS I THINK THERE'S A
THERE'S ALREADY SOME FUNDING ON
THIS AND IF THERE'S SOME REALLY
SPECIFIC. NEEDS THAT ARE NOT
COVERED- THROUGH THE- REGULAR
PROCESS THEN- I'M SURE WE COULD
FIGURE THAT WAS UP. OKAY-
COMPANION SENATOR. COMMENTS.
OKAY IF IT WAS AVAILABLE IN THE
SPRING. OKAY WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE WHO WAS HERE
EVERYONE I'M NOT HERE BUT
EVERYONE WHO WAS AVAILABLE ALL
OF YOUR PRESENTATIONS- WERE
GREAT WONDERFUL AND THE ALL THE
WORK THAT WENT INTO WITH ALL OF
YOU WHO HAD SOMETHING TO SAY BUT
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE. WE NOTICED
THAT WE APPRECIATE YOU THANK YOU
ALL ERY MUCH- SO- DUE TO THE-
GIVE ME JUST GO THROUGH THIS
REAL QUICK WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. REGARDING ANY OF
THE ISSUES DISCUSSED TODAY AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX ONE TWO FIVE.
TWO EIGHT EIGHT DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS TO CHEER UP WE MIGHT
LIMIT TEST OUT LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. OF FOR NOW I'M GOING
TO ASK THAT- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDE COMMENTS UP
WITHIN APPROXIMATELY A MINUTE
THIS BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM. PLEASE COME
FORWARD I SEE. I'M SORRY ARE
YOUR FORWARD THIS MY GLASSES IF
YOU WOULD INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND- IDENTIFY THE ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE COMMENTING ON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
STEVE MCCARTHY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND A COALITION OF MORE THAN
TWENTY BUSINESS GROUPS ON ISSUE
NUMBER ONE- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT PACKAGE- YEAH I THINK THE
BREADTH OF THE SUPPORT FOR THIS
PACKAGE SPEAKS TO- ITS
IMPORTANCE AND ALSO TO THE
BREADTH OF THE IMPACT. OF THE
WAR SEE ON OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WHETHER THAT BE- NOT
JUST RETAIL THE TRAVEL AND
TOURISM- OUR BUSINESS DISTRICTS
IN OUR OUR COMMUNITIES TOWNS AND
CITIES. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THE CHP'S TASK
FORCE INTO ADDITIONAL PARTS OF
THE STATE THE- DID PROPOSAL FOR
DEDICATED PROSECUTORS THE
SPECIAL THEFT UNIT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
LAW LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT GRANTS
AND I WON'T GET INTO ALL OF OUR
COMMENTS GIVEN THAT I HAVE. A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME BUT I JUST
DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE- FOUR SEED
FREQUENTLY WHAT WE SEE WITH
REGARD TO THIS CRIME IS A FEW
REGULATORS WHO- WHO STEVE WHO
RECRUIT INDIVIDUALS TO STEAL ON
THEIR BEHALF AND THEN FENCE
THOSE ITEMS ONLINE OR THROUGH
FLEA MARKETS STREET VENDORS FALL
SHORT FALL STOREFRONTS YOU NAME
IT- THEY PREY ON MINORS HOMELESS
ADDICTS. ANYONE WHO COULD THEY
CAN GET TO STEAL FROM THEM FOR A
FEW DOLLARS DISMANTLING THESE O.
R. C. NETWORKS IS A CRITICAL
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
TO THIS RECENT UPRISING IN OR
SEE IN RETAIL THEFT- AS I
MENTIONED WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THE CONTENT OF THE-
OF THE OF THESE PROPOSALS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO. THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. AND YOUR
STAFF IN THE COMING MONTHS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
TEST AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR
WAITING. ALL OF THIS TIME IS
GREATLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M CHRISTINA
TO KERR- REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC TELEVISION WE ARE ALL THE
PUBLIC BROADCASTERS IN THE STATE
COMMENTING ON THE CALLAWAY YES
BUDGET ITEM EARLY EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEM. AND AS MADAM
CHAIR INDICATED OUR GROUP IS
REQUESTING ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT A
PREVIOUS PILOT OF THE EARLY
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM. TO
THE REST OF THE STATE A PILOT
THAT OCCURRED SEVERAL YEARS AGO
BETWEEN CAL- YES IN THE PUBLIC
BROADCASTING STATIONS RESULTED
IN A SUCCESSFUL EFFORT WHICH
REDUCE THE EARLY EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEM TO LESS THAN
THREE SECONDS FOR THE FIRST
TIME. USING THIS SPECIAL DATA
CASTING TECHNOLOGY A FIRE
STATION COULD RECEIVE A WARNING
IN ADVANCE OF AN EARTHQUAKE THE
FIRE STATION COULD ROLL UP ITS
DOORS GET THE TRUCKS OUT OF THE
STATION BEFORE THE- DOORS WERE
BENT ON THEIR FRAMES OR A
HOSPITAL COULD RECEIVE A TIMELY
WARNING. WE WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR FOR
RAISING THE ISSUE IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF DIRECTOR
GHILARDUCCI EVERYTHING SOUNDS
RATHER PROMISING AND SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AS WELL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE- IT'S
NICE TO SEE A REAL IN PERSON
TESTIMONY BEING GIVEN. WE WERE
USED TO THIS THESE PLACES IN
EVERY SEAT. IN THE HOUSE WAS-
SOMEBODY WITHIN IT SO- THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOU BOTH. OUT NOW WE
WILL. MOVE ON. OKAY. MODERATOR
IF YOU'RE SO WHAT THIS WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND IF YOU WOULD LET US
KNOW PROXIMATE LI HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END OF THE ROW AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SIX M. Q.
OKAY MODERATOR YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JEREMY I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF AND SHE IN AT THE WHITE
NONPROFIT THAT ORGANIZED BY
MEMBERS BOTH INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
OF PRISON TO AFFECT POLICY
CHANGE I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE HAVE MORE THAN FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA AS
IN. HUNDREDS OF TRAINED TRAINED
OUTSIDE ORGANIZERS FOR CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION ITEM ONE
COMBATING ORGANIZED THREE
CONTACT CALIFORNIA CANNOT AND
SHOULD NOT RELY ON DATA THAT'S
BEING REPORTED BY RETAILERS I
THANK YOU FOR INCREASED RETAIL
THAT. AND LIKE TO HELP HIGHLIGHT
THE L. A. L. AND ALICE INSPECTED
ON RTAIL FACT DOES NOT SUPPORT
A CONCLUSION THAT WE HELP. THAT
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
THE STATE. THE HELP THAT THAT
DOES. PERSISTENT INCOME. AND I
CAN STRESS ARE CITED AS
EXTENSION EIGHT TRACK DRIVING
FACTORS. THEY SHOULDN'T BE
ADDRESSED BY FUNDING UNIT OF
MEASURE IT ON THE BACK AND WHEN
WE COULD BE FINDING RESOURCES
FOR PEOPLE WHICH ARE ALSO
PREVENTS PREVENTIVE. POVERTY
OPPOSITION FORTY SEVEN HAD COME
UNDER PARTICULAR SCRUTINY BUT I
STAYED IN THE BACKGROUND
REFERENCES. THERE IS NO CLEAR
LINK BETWEEN THE PASSAGE OF PROP
FORTY SEVEN IN PROPERTY CRIME.
IS MANUFACTURED PANIC AROUND
PROP FORTY SEVEN IN RETAIL FAST
SERVICE CLINICAL GROUP CALLS BUT
NO REAL PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS
GOING FORWARD. INSTEAD OF WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO INVEST IN TRUE
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR ALL BLACK.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
CALLING. NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. PLEASE CALL. YOU CAN
YOU CHECK THE NUMBER THANK YOU
DOCTOR I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION THANK HI
TRACY HOW HAVING A CHILD AND I
TRY TO TREAT. NON ASIAN NINE
UNDER THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES THE ONE EXTRACT OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
INVESTMENT IMPLEMENTING THE NINE
EIGHT NINE THAT GOES IN LIFE IS
TO LIE THE AUTHOR OR THE
LEGISLATURE IMITATION TO ENSURE
THE HIGHER NINETY EIGHT
ESTIMATES PROPERLY FUNDED BY
PATTY MARQUIS ON PHONE LINES AS
AUTHORIZED BY THE NATIONAL.
HOTLINE HM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. MY NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SURE NUMBERS BOB LANE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BE ABLE HELP AGENCIES
AND SUPPORT- ISSUE NINE UNDER
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. SHOULD BE A J.
STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT THE
FUNDING AND MAINTAINING INTER
OPERABILITY BETWEEN NINE ONE ONE
AND- I'M STILL CONSIDERING THE
PENDING JULY IMPLEMENTATION
DEADLINE WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR AN
OPERABILITY BUT AFTER THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE HOTLINE
DESIGNATION ACT ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED WITH STATE FUNDS AND
THE APPROPRIATE FEES. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT PROPOSALS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HANNAH BACK OFF I AM CALLING IN
FROM COWBOY FOOD CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST AND OLDEST YOUR RUN
ORGANIZATION TODAY I WANTED TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE. WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
INCREASING FUNDING FOR AT NINE
EIGHT EIGHT AS OTHERS MENTIONED
WITH THE JULY- DEADLINE RAPIDLY
APPROACHING BRAND WOMAN PATIENT
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE BEGAN
BUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY TRANSFER
TRANSFER MENTAL HEALTH I CALLED.
TO CONNECT VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS IN A LIFE SAVING
HELP THEY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR CALLING PRE SHADED
THANK. YOU NEXT PLEASE MODERATOR
. THANK YOU I'M TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR
TORONTO AND MEMBERS- I MADE HER
OUT WITH THE NATIONAL UNION OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS OR AND YOU
REACHED OUT TO YOU THE LARGEST
UNION OF PRIVATE SECTOR MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICIAN IN CALIFORNIA
I'M ALSO CALLING IN TO SUPPORT
ISSUE NINE. HUNDRED YEAH THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR NINE
EIGHT. YEAH- CLEARLY IMPORTANT
TO MAINTAIN THEIR OPERABILITY
BETWEEN NINE ELEVEN NINETY NINE.
I MEAN WE OFFERED SUPPORT-
FINDING THEM AND THEN- PASSING
ON ITS LOFTY- I'M ONLINE DOES
NOT CORRECT. THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE HOTLINE ACT AND
EVERYTHING THIS MORNING INSTEAD
OF MUCH NEEDED EXPAND NON NON
POLICE MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSE
AND THANKOUR. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
THANK. THANK YOU FOR PRE SHADED
NEXT PLEASE HI. THANK YOU RYAN
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS TARA GAMBLE EVENING WITH
THE STEINBERG AND PICK HERE WE
ARE THE CO SPONSORS THAT- ALONG
WITH A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
FAMILY BILL NINE EIGHT EIGHT
IMPLEMENTED NINE EIGHT EIGHT
CRATE THE LINE SPEAKING TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT FUNDING
FOR- WE ASKED TO MAINTAIN THAT
INTER OPERABILITY I WON'T BE
GONE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT MANY
PEOPLE HAVE. WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT IN ADDITION TO
FINDING THAT CRITICAL PIECE WE
DO NEED TO FIND THE ENTIRETY OF
THE SYSTEM AND AGAIN CUT TO WHAT
OTHER PEOPLE LOOK BAD WITH
STRONGLY SUPPORT- HOLISTIC FIGHT
FINANCING STRATEGY INCLUDING
THAT SMALL TELEPHONE SHE-
SUPPORTED BY FEDERAL LEGISLATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THAT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR CALLING NEXT
MODERATOR. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWENTY CLEAR GO AHEAD. HELLO
SHERRIN NUMBERS AREN'T THANK YOU
THE COUNTY FOR I'M ALSO CALLING
INTO POOR AND ISSUE NINE UNDER
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
THAT WE OFFER IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE INVESTMENT TOWARD BETTER
OPERABILITY BETWEEN ONE I NEED
A- VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE BEST
MY ALSO URGED LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ADDITIONAL HIGH NEEDS
INVESTMENT CONCORDANCE BETWEEN A
BOYFRIEND AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CRISIS RESPONSE SYSTEM IN ITS
ENTIRETY. WE ALL ARE SUPPORTED
THE BEST THEY'RE A SMALL FEE ON
TOP OF MY DOCTOR I GOT A
NATIONAL. HOTLINE TO THE PATIENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT. THANK YOU TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS ADRIAN
SOMETHING WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND WE'RE ALSO HERE TO
SUPPORT YOU SHE NINE UNDER THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
NINE EIGHT EIGHT INVESTMENT WE
DID WANTED TO RELAY OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE- INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. OKAY. IF THERE ARE NO MORE
COLORS AND HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SENATORS
DO YOU HAVE ANY FINAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS I DO NOT DO NOT
OKAY- THANK YOU EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COOPERATION THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WHO WAITED ALL THE
TIME AND WE'RE VERY PATIENT
ABOUT IT IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AGAIN
TO ALL OF OUR STAFF THANK YOU
DOCTOR BAG BUILT AND EVERYONE
WHO MADE THIS POSSIBLE WE DEPEND
ON YOU SO MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU AND-
THIS COMMITTEE IS NOW ADJOURNED.